GOOD
MORNING.
MORE MAY ONE WELCOME TO OUR
FIRST --
HEARING FOR THE TWO YEAR SESSION --
WILL HAVE TO WAIT TO SAVAGE
QUORUM BUT WE'LL CERTAINLY HERE.
THE FIRST BILLS AND DIE I THINK
IT BE APPROPRIATE TO WELCOME OUR
NEW COLLEAGUE ON THE COMMITTEE
GARCIA.
AND WELCOME SO --
WITH FIRST BILL WE WILL HEAR IS --
A. B. TWO OH NINE AND THE MOAN
PARKS ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
GRANT PROGRAM.
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWO OH NINE
ESTABLISHES THE OUTDOOR EQUITY
GRANT FUNDING PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE THE ABILITY
OF UNDERSERVED IN AT RISK
POPULATIONS TO PARTICIPATE IN
OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS.
AB TWO OH NINE REQUIRES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION GIVE PRIORITY FUNDING
FOR OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN BOTH URBAN
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES ACROSS
NORTH IN.
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHICH PRIMARILY TARGET
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS CALIFORNIA
HAS TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY STATE
PARKS AND MILLIONS OF ACRES OF
PUBLIC LAND THAT EXHIBIT THE
NATURAL BEAUTY AND HISTORY OF
OUR STATE.
AND INCLUDE NUMEROUS EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES ACT ACCESS TO SUCH
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES HOWEVER IS
OFTEN OUT OF REACH FOR
COMMUNITIES AND STUDENTS AND LOW
INCOME AND OTHERWISE
MARGINALIZED.
AREAS IN THE STATE.
WITH ME TODAY FOUNDER OF LATINO
OUTDOORS AND ONE AT THE NANO
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY AT FOR THE AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR GARCIA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SO MY
NAME IS JOSE GONZALEZ I'M THE
FOUNDER OF THAT THE NOT DOORS
AND I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE ORGANIZATION.
AS A SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MONIQUE LIMON A.
B. -- TWO OH
NINE LET YOU KNOW DOORS IS A
UNIQUE LET THE NO LET
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO CREDIT
AND NATIONAL COMMUNITY LEADERS
IN THIS --
IN THIS WORKING IN THE SPACE WE
STARTED IN GREW OUT OF
CALIFORNIA IN THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY.
IS ONE OF THE COMMITTEE HEARD IN
PASSED LAST YEAR AND SO WE'RE
ASKING -- TO
CONTINUE THAT AND NOW ME TO
RESTATE SOME COMMENTS THAT I
THAT I HAVE OFFERED BEFORE AS
WELL THE STRESS WHAT'S WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS.
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS IN NATURE
SEEMS LIKE IT OUT TO BE A BIRTH
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW I BECAME A PRODUCT OF THE
ACCESS AND THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS HAD TO OFFER
I'M AN IMMIGRANT TO THIS COUNTRY
IS BORN IN MAY HE GO AND MY
FIRST CONNECTION EXPOSURE TO THE
OF STATE PARKS NATIONAL PARKS.
HAPPEN HERE --
I AND WE ENJOYED SO MANY THINGS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT I THINK OFTEN
WE MAY FORGET OR TAKE FOR
GRANTED I GREW UP IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO EVEN THE ASSEMBLY WAS
ONLY LIKE TWO HOURS AWAY.
I DON'T GET TO EXPERIENCE A LOT
OF THESE CONNECTIONS UNTIL LATER
IN MY LIFE AND THEN ESPECIALLY
ONCE I BEGAN TO WORK WITH THAT
THE NOT DOORS TO BE ABLE TO
CONNECT THIS WITH ONE FAMILIES.
AS I THINK IT'S ALSO ARE EASY TO
OVERLOOK THE HARD FOUGHT BATTLE
SUPERSTAR THESE PLACES --
THAT WE PUT IN A LOT OF WORK IN
INVEST ALLOW FOR THE CONNECTION
AND ACCESS OF THE COMMUNITIES IN
THE PEOPLE THAT WE WANT THEM TO
STAY CONNECTED AND INVESTED.
AND CONTINUE TO BE THE PRESENT
AND FUTURE STEWARDS OF THESE
LANDSCAPES.
AS THE AS THE DEMOGRAPHICS
CONTINUE TO SHIFT.
AND SO WHAT I'M ASKING FOR IS
FOR THESE REASONS THAT LET YOU
KNOW TO A STRONG SUPPORTER AB.
TWO NINE THANKFUL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE ONE FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS MATTER.
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION AND
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE HI.
THANK YOU CHAIR MY NAME IS ONE
OF THEM WE DON'T KNOW --
WITHOUT ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE WANT TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WE MOURN FOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL
ONLINE CALIFORNIA IS A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION NATIONWIDE
ORGANIZATION THAT IS DEDICATED
TO CONSERVING.
AND HABITATS FOR THE BENEFIT OF
NOT JUST THE BIRDS --
BUT ALSO PEOPLE. FOR THEM TO
ENJOY THE OUTDOORS IN JOY WHAT
HAS BEEN A NATIONAL TREASURE AND
ALSO A STATE TREASURER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND AND AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE PROTECT OF THE
OUTDOORS AND PUT PEOPLE OUT IN
PLACES THAT A LOT ARE ALLOWED TO
ENJOY THESE.
THESE AREAS THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY.
YOU KNOW WHAT GRANT LYCOS I SAID
FOR YOU TO LEARN ABOUT ENJOY THE
STATE'S OUTDOOR.
AREAS IN NATURAL RESOURCES AND
SPECIFICALLY IT PRIORITIZES
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION TO AND
FROM THESE AREAS.
ADDRESSING WHAT IS OFTEN THE
LARGEST BARRIERS TO ACCESS TO
THESE COMMUNITIES.
VERY SIMILAR TO HOST A STORY I I
TO LIMóN IMMIGRANT TO THIS
COUNTRY.
AND I NEVER REALLY WERE WAS
EXPOSED TO THE OUTDOORS UNTIL I
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL --
THROUGH SPORTS RECREATION
PROGRAMS ARE AND I THINK THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW.
FOLKS LIKE ME N. O. SE --
TO BE ABLE TO LEARN ABOUT THE
OUTDOORS BE EXPOSED TO THE
OUTDOORS AT A MUCH EARLIER AGE --
WHERE RESOURCES ARE NOT --
FULLY AVAILABLE SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE FULLY SUPPORT AB TWO
OH NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THOSE OF YOU WHO WOULD LIKE.
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
AS WELL AS A SCHOOL AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
MEMBER DOUG HOUSTON REPRESENTING
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA PARK IT WRECKS
SOCIETIES HERE CONSORTIUM.
AND ABOUT IT A COALITION
REPRESENTING ABOUT 80% OF THE
FOLKS THAT ARE YOU ON YOUR LATE
SUPPORT LAST.
ON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT APOLOGIES FOR
NOT GETTING OUR LETTER IN ON
TIME THAT WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING TREES A BIRD WHICH
ON BEHALF HILL THE BAY SURFRIDER
SOME GENERATION ADVISORS AND THE
REST OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION AND SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING THE TAIL CROWN
TO HAVE THE MOUNTAINS RECREATION
AND CONSERVATION AUTHORITY ON
STRONG SUPPORTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE.
IN FAVOR OKAY GOOD ACTORS MY
NAME IS MICHAEL WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA --
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AN URGENT
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
ON BEHALF OF COMMITTEE NATURE
CONNECTION FRIENDS OF THOSE ON
HE SAID I REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT ANNALS THANK YOU LIST
NEVER LAND TRUST IN SUPPORT
ALRIGHT I DIDN'T SEE ANYONE
RUSSIAN.
SPEAKING OPPOSITION OUT IN BACK
TODAY'S ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISS VAUGHN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
RECOGNIZE YOUR YOUR YOUR NEED
FOR REACHING OUT TO GIVE ACCESS
TO TO MORE PEOPLE. ONE OF THE
THINGS I'D LIKE TO DISCUSS WITH
YOU IS THE ABILITY TO MAKE IT SO
ALL PEOPLE HAVE.
AN OPEN ACCESS FOR THIS AND WELL.
OFTENTIMES WE HEAR THE TERMS YOU
KNOW.
IS LIMITED TO THE PEOPLE WHO GET
A REDUCE MAIL ARE.
THERE FOSTER USE OR THERE ARE
OTHER BEFORE BECAUSE THEIR
LIMITED ENGLISH SPEAKING. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE FORGET IS
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE THE
CLOSEST TO OUR PARKS.
ARE EXCLUDED BECAUSE THEY DON'T
MEET CERTAIN.
BRACKETS.
HOW DO WE OVERCOME THAT?
IS THERE A WAY TO WORK THROUGH
YOUR BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW ALL
PEOPLE HAVE THE SAME ENJOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY.
BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE CERTAIN
LIMITATIONS.
THAT MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE.
SO HOW DO WE OPEN THAT DOOR AND
AS TO THE LANGUAGE IN YOUR BILL
THAT WILL BE NON EXCLUSIONARY IF
YOU WILL [inaudible]
HELPING OTHERS.
MANY OF THOSE OTHERS WHO
ACTUALLY LIVE WITHIN FIVE TEN
FIFTEEN MINUTES OF THE ENTRANCE
OF THOSE PARKS.
DON'T GIVE THEM THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY I AND I I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS --
CERTAINLY AS SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTS.
THE AREA A DO YOU AND HAVING
SERVED ON A SCHOOL BOARD I SAW
HOW MANY OF THE STUDENTS I SERVE
THAT LIVED MINUTES FROM THE
OCEAN ARE PARK NEVER GOT --
TO VISIT THE OCEAN --
PARK SO I VERY MUCH --
RESPECT AND UNDERSTAND AT THAT
POSITION I'D LOVE TO LIVE OPEN
THIS UP TO EVERYONE ON THE
FUNDING WOULD BE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT IF WE WERE OPENING IT
UP I THINK THE TARGET --
HERE HAS TO DO WITH THOSE THAT
ARE MOST DISADVANTAGED ON THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE'S NOT
OTHERS WHO ARE DISADVANTAGED IN
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE STOP.
ENSURING THAT WE WORK TO HELP
EVERY FOR PURPOSES OF THIS BILL
IT IS LIMITED IN SCOPE --
IT ALSO MEANS IT'S LIMITED IN
FUNDING BUT CERTAINLY IF THERE
WERE WAYS IN TERMS OF INCREASING
ACCESS --
GENERALLY THOSE WOULD.
BE IDEAS THAT I WOULD BE VERY
OPEN TO AT THIS BILL DID GET OUT
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT LAST
YEAR AND WE INCLUDED AN
AMENDMENT IN THE BILL.
ABOUT A ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS --
THAT WAS NOT LIMITED TO ANY ONE
PARTICULAR GROUP IS VERY FOCUSED
ON MY VERY SPECIFIC AREA AND SO
THAT THE BILL ENDED UP BEING
VETOED --
BUT CERTAINLY THERE IS MUCH WORK
TO DO ON ENSURING THAT EVERYONE
HAS ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS.
AND AND THAT THAT'S WHERE THE
CONFLICT IS FOR ME THE BEING
SOMEONE WHO WAS ACTUALLY ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE AT THE VERY END.
I STAYED NEUTRAL IN COMMITTEE
AND TRY TO WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE
FOR SOLUTIONS IN RESOLVING A LOT
OF THAT NOT ONLY YOUR RIGHT THE
GOVERNOR DID VETO.
THE ACTION AS IT GOT TO HIS DESK.
WITH ALL ALL OF THE SAME FOCUS
THAT I HAD THEN I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOUR OFFICE IN TRYING.
TO SEE THAT WE CAN CRAFT A BILL
THAT HAS LANGUAGE THAT WOULD BE
INCLUSIVE NOT EXCLUSIVE AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU AN
ICE.
SHARE DISTRICTS THAT --
ARE SIMILAR IN KIND.
I HAVE A 100% OF YOU SOMEBODY.
AND I'VE GOT SOME.
WHAT'S CLASS WONDERS OF THE
WORLD.
AND THE TOP SEVEN ACTUALLY. ONE
OF AND IT'S DISHEARTENING TO
KNOW THAT STUDENTS.
THAT ARE JUST MINUTES AWAY FROM
THE GATE.
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO SEE SUCH
WONDERS.
CAN'T GET IN.
AS OUR LIMITED SO IF YOU AND I
COULD WORK ON THAT AND IF THE
CHAIR WOULD HELP US TO WORK ON
ACHIEVING A A SOLUTION.
THAT BRIDGES THIS AND ALLOWS.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE TO HAVE
THAT SAME ACCESS THAT THIS IS
TRYING TO GET FOR JUST A CERTAIN
GROUP.
I WOULD BE TICKLED TO DEATH SO.
I'LL STAY OFF OF IT JUST TO GIVE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO WORK IN
DIALOGUE ON TODAY IF THERE'S A
COMMITMENT ON YOUR PART TO WORK
ON THAT.
I AM HAPPY TO I MEAN CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION A A THINK THAT
THE BILL IS IS LIMITED IN SCOPE
BUT I CERTAINLY AM HAPPY TO
PARTNER WITH YOU IN TERMS OF
THINKING.
MORE BROADLY HOW WE GET THOSE
THAT LIVE NEAR COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE NO ACCESS TO A OR LIMITED
ACCESS TO SOME OF THESE NATURAL
SPACES.
THANK THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
LET ME STOP IS TO POUR MORE
QUICK.
AND THEN WILL --
TAKE YOUR QUESTION.
WELL WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL AND
WELCOME TO OUR YOU MEMBER BRIAN
DAHLE.
LET'S ESTABLISH QUORUM FIRST
NAME WILL WILL GO BACK TO YOUR
QUESTION AFTER [inaudible]
THE DOCTORS [inaudible]
QUESTION.
EDUARDO GARCIA PRESENT
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
CHOI HERE CHIU [inaudible]
DELHI HERE [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA LEVINE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
WOOD.
ALL RIGHT LET ME JUST MAKE A
COMMENT I HAPPY.
TO SEE THE TAPE THE CONVERSATION
AS IT RELATES TO THE KIND OF THE
SCOPE BY.
I WOULD GAS AND I DON'T KNOW THE
DEMOGRAPHICS SPECIFICALLY OF THE
FOLKS IN YOUR DISTRICT MISTER
BIGELOW BUT I WOULD GUESS THAT.
SOCIO ECONOMICS --
PROBABLY WOULD BE VERY SIMILAR --
IF -- THE
POPULATION ARE UNABLE.
TO VISIT YOSEMITE PARK IT I
THINK IN THE INTENTION IS VERY
SIMILAR AND I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
THE SAME GROUPS OF INDIVIDUALS --
MEET SOME OF THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE REFERRING
TO HERE IN THIS PARTICULAR.
NARAL SCOPE OF A OF THE BILL BUT
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE YOU AND
THE AUTHOR.
ON THAT SO THE DOCTOR HAD A
QUESTION THAT.
THANK YOU CHAIR --
I HEAR YOUR POINTS ARE.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW MORE
SPECIFIC SO.
IF THE OP.
MORE OF FUNDING IS MADE
AVAILABLE OR FOR OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCE SO --
PARTICULARLY FOR THE I THINK
THAT YOUR EMPHASIS ALSO ON THE
CHILDREN OF A DISADVANTAGE
COMMUNITY WAR.
NOT PEOPLE OF BUT AT THE RISK
POPULATION --
UNDERSERVED.
THE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE OF THE
CATEGORIES --
BUT THE IF THE FUNDING WAS A MAY
DEVELOP OR HOW WOULD YOU.
GIVE THEM OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPERIENCE IT IS SAYS THROUGH
THE SCHOOL AN OUTDOOR.
OF VISITED POOL PLANS SO OR
FAMILIES WOULD LIKE TO MAKE --
OUTDOOR VACATION AND APPLY FOR
IT THE BECAUSE HAS SOON.
AT THE EXPERIENCE OR CHILDREN.
WILL HAVE A FOR OUTDOOR NATURE
MADE THAT WOULD BE ORG
BENEFICIAL.
THE WHETHER YOU HAVE MONEY ONE
NOT THE WAS TO FAMILIESTHAT MAY
NOT HAVE TENDS. TO GIVE THEM
OPPORTUNITY TO ALL OF THE WAR --
EXPERIENCE SO IS A NOT THE MMHM
MMHM.
SOMETIMES A MONEY ISSUE --
SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
SPECIFICALLY HOW THIS FUND.
WILL HELP.
HOW YOU GONNA IMPLEMENT THAT THE
FUNDS ARE MADE ABOUT?
THE IDEA OF THIS PARTICULAR FIND
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND IT COULD
BE AND NON PROFIT CAN BE A BREAK
FOR A BROADER AN ENTITY IT CAN
BE A REGIONAL ENTITY WHAT APPLY
FOR GRANTS TO THE DEPARTMENT.
OF UP PARKS AND SO THAT THAT'S
REALLY HOW THE PROGRAM WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED --
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT UP MODEL OF FUNDING
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES FOR STUDENTS
AND TARA MONEY WOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE AND A DIFFERENT.
ENTITIES OF THE A COMMUNITY
ORDER APPLY FOR PLAN.
LIKE APPLICATION BASED
[inaudible]
I SEE.
AND THEN ORNEA.
SO THAT THE POPULATION WILL HAVE
TO BE YOU HAVE TO PROVE THAT THE
YOU WALK DISADVANTAGED WHO ARE
AT RISK FAMILY.
YOU WOULD PROVE THAT THE PROGRAM
THAT YOU ARE FACILITATING IS
TARGETED TO LOW INCOME AND I
WANT TO BE CLOSE CLEAR THAT LOW
INCOME IS NOT ETHNIC OR RACE
BASED.
FLOWING COMPANY FOR DISEASE YEAH
DISADVANTAGED AND OTHER
CATEGORIES HAVE YOU DONE ANY --
THAT ONE'S DUTY --
ONLY DISADVANTAGED --
AT RISK.
OF POPULATION WOULD HAVE A MUCH
LESS EXPERIENCE OF THE OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCE OF VERSUS.
SO TO SPEAK --
WENT TO FAMILY MORE EXPERIENCES
HISTORICALLY IN RESEARCH SAYS
YES THAT THOSE THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGED HAVE LESS ACCESS
TO THE OUTDOORS.
THAN THOSE WHO ARE NOT
DISADVANTAGED.
THANK YOU MISTER DALI AND
WALKING TO GET.
MEDICINE A GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR I APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT --
I'M LA OFF YOUR BILL TODAY AND
I'LL SHARE WITH YOU WHY --
I SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE.
QUITE A BIT OVER THE LAST SIX
YEARS AND WE HAD A REALLY BIG
ISSUE WITH OUR PARKS WAS GOING
TO CLOSE AT ONE POINT AND WE
HAVE A BACK LAWS LOG OF MAKING
THIS THE PARK'S THEMSELVES I
HAVE.
SEVERAL MY DISTRICT THAT WE WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THEM OPEN --
SO I WANT TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN
A PROBE SO WHERE THE FUNDING
GETS -- HOW
WE'RE GONNA COME FROM IS GOING
TO COME FROM THE?
PARKS BUDGET ITSELF --
I'M GONNA HAVE A HARD TIME
SUPPORT AND EVEN WHEN IT GETS
THE FOR BUT I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THAT OPPORTUNITY I KNOW THIS IS
NOT THE PLACE WE GET MONEY I DO
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU THAT TIME
WE NEED TO GET PEOPLE --
THOSE LOW AND UNDERSERVED FOLKS
OUT.
AND EXPERIENCING THE GREAT
BEAUTIES OF THE STATE AND THAT
UP TOO SO I I WANT TO SHARE THAT
WITH YOU AND I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
BUT IT ALL BOILS DOWN --
TO OR HOW THE RESOURCES GET
DIVIDED UP BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
BACKLOG OF MAINTENANCE IT NEEDS
TO BE NEED TO CURSE OF THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING FOR INK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS WANT
COMMON.
QUESTIONS CONCERNS COMPLAINTS
THE MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
THE SECOND.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECT THE ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE OKAY SO THE MOTION BY
GARCIA SECOND BY.
DOCTOR WOULD.
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
WITNESSES.
ROCCA.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA I
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING. TO DELHI.
DALY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
WOULD.
WOULD I ONE MORE FULLER KEEP ON
THE CALL OPEN AND FOR ADD ONS
GREAT THANK YOU.
IF I IF I CAN ASK THAT WE ADOPT
THE RULES OF FOR THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE TWO YEAR SESSION --
WE HAVE A MOTION MEMBERS GARCIA
SECOND BY DOT THE WOULD --
LAST FOUR ROLL CALL OPTIONAL
RULES.
ON THE ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE
RULES EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI NO CHOI NO CHIU
[inaudible]
DELHI.
SALLY I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
WOULD.
WOULD I OKAY.
I WOULDN'T.
WANT TO CHANGE THAT OR NOT SORRY
I WOULD NEVER STAND.
OKAY.
YEAH. ONE OF YOU KNOW.
VOTE CHANGE DELHI NO.
YOU CAN BE ENOUGH. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX EIGHTY TWO OKAY WE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN ALSO FOR
OTHER MEMBERS --
TO CASTER VOTE I'M GONNA SEE IF
I CAN WE GET A MOTION ON THE
PROPOSED A CONSENT CALENDAR WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS ARE.
MOTION BY RUBIO SECOND BY MISS
FLOREA --
BROKEN.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM NUMBER. TWO EIGHTY TO DO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE EIGHTY
TWO TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GARCIA HI GARCIA BY --
IT ALONE.
HI.
BIGELOW AYE CHOI AYE CHU CHOI
AYE CHU.
DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE CRISTINA GARCIA.
FIRST HERE I GLORIA [inaudible]
LEVINE.
I WALK OVER THE RUBIO AYE SALAS.
WOOD [inaudible]
WHAT TIME?
OKAY WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THAT OPEN
ALSO FOR THE MEMBERS IT.
AT ON WILL --
BACK TO THE AGENDA AND ITEM FOR
WHICH THEY BE.
TWO SEVEN THREE SALAS
POSSIBILITIES A MOMENT AND SALAS
FLETCHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB TWO SEVENTY THREE WHAT PER
HER PROHIBIT FOR TRAPPING IN THE
SALE ROB FOR IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORICALLY TRAPPING FOR FOR
WAS A LARGE INDUSTRY.
AD BUT TODAY FOR TRAPPING
CALIFORNIA IT IS DONE AN
EXTREMELY SMALL SCALE RELATIVE
TO ITS HEYDAY IS IN THE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LIFE THERE WERE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
TRAPPERS WHO RECEIVED AN
ESTIMATED REVENUE AT TEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE TOTAL FOR FOR SALES.
HOWEVER CONTINUES BEING
INHERENTLY CRUEL AND INHUMANE
PRACTICE FOR THE ANIMALS TRAPPED
AND CAN HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS KILLING
PADS OR PROTECTED WILDLIFE. FOR
TRAPPING CALIFORNIA'S ALSO
SUBSIDIZED BY TAXPAYERS DESPITE
REQUIREMENTS IN STATE LAW FOR
TRAPPING PROGRAM TO COVER ITS
OWN COST TRAPPING LICENSE FEES
DO NOT COVER THE ACTUAL COST OF
IMPLEMENTING THE STATE'S FOR
TRAPPING PROGRAM.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SEASON COST OF A
TRAPPING LICENSE WAS ONLY A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN DOLLARS.
BASED ON THE MANAGEMENT OF
LICENSE ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THIS
IS LESS THAN IT SHOULD BE TO
GENERATE ENOUGH REVENUE TO COVER
THE COST OF THE TRAINING PROGRAM
ARE THE TRAPPING PROGRAM.
JUST FOUR YEARS AGO THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION BANNED COMMERCIAL
BOBCAT TRAPPING AND PART BASED
ON SIMILAR CONCERNS REGARD THE
COST OF THE PROGRAM.
AB TWO SEVENTY THREE WOULD
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE
WILDLIFE FROM CRUEL AN OUTDATED
PRACTICE THE BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
THE TRAPPING OF FOR BURYING OR
NON GAME MAMMAL FOR THE PURPOSES
OF RECREATION OR COMMERCE INFER.
PROHIBIT THE SALE PROFFER
ELIMINATE THE LICENSE FOR FOR
DEALERS FOR AGENTS HOWEVER THIS
BILL WOULD MAINTAIN THE ABILITY
TO TRAP IN ORDER TO MANAGE
WILDLIFE WHICH MAYBE INJURING
CROPS OR PROPERTY. FOR THAT
REASON I RESPECT LAST FOR NIGHT
OUT.
THANK YOU EVER WITNESSES
[inaudible]
SPEAK.
GOOD MORNING I'M JENNY KEATING
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATION WITH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE FIVE YEARS AGO A SINGLE
TRAPPER OPERATING ALONG THE
BOUNDARY OF JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL
PARK KILLED ENOUGH BOBCATS IN
ONE SEASON. TO SEVERELY DEPLETE
THE LOCAL POPULATION OF THIS
SPECIES TURNING AN ANIMAL
FREQUENTLY OBSERVED AND
APPRECIATED BY TOURISTS AND
LOCALS ALIKE INTO A SPECIES NOW
FIVE YEARS LATER.
THAT IS STILL RARELY SEEN.
IN RESPONSE CALIFORNIA WISELY
BAND BOBCAT TRAPPING IN THE
STATE BUT THE PROBLEM ISN'T
LIMITED TO BOBCATS AS
APPROXIMATELY A DOZEN NATIVE
SPECIES ARE STILL TARGETED FOR
THEIR FOR LAST YEAR A SINGLE
TRAPPER IN AROUND THE RECENTLY
DESIGNATED SAN GABRIEL MOUNTAINS
NATIONAL MONUMENT.
KILLED MORE THAN A HUNDRED GRAY
FOXES.
THE SAME GRADE GIRL MONUMENT WAS
DECLARED IN PART INSTANCE.
IN SIGNIFICANT PART TO PROTECT
WILDLIFE FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
YET CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
ALLOWS A SINGLE FUR TRAPPER TO
SYSTEMATICALLY DEPLETE THE
WILDLIFE IN THIS AREA TO THE
DETRIMENT OF NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS
AND THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO
VISIT THE MONUMENT ANNUALLY.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THERE ARE
MORE FOXES IN OTHER REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA THE I'M REGULATING
UNREGULATED TRAPPING THAT OCCURS
UNDER CURRENT LAW CAN HAVE REAL
IMPACTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AFFECTING WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
EFFORTS AND THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
AND RECREATION IN THE AREA. FOR
THE VISITORS AND RESIDENTS OF
JOSHUA TREE WHO LOST THEIR
BOBCATS IT MATTERED. FOR THE
VISITORS OF SAN GABRIEL
MOUNTAINS NATIONAL MONUMENT WHO
ARE MUCH LESS LIKELY TO SEE A
GRAY FOX IT MATTERS.
BY PROHIBITING COMMERCIAL FOR
TRAPPING IN CALIFORNIA AB TWO
SEVENTY SIX THREE WILL PROTECT
PROTECT NOT JUST THE WILDLIFE
AND ECOLOGY OF THE STATE.
BUT ALSO THE TOURISM DEPENDENT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE TIED TO
HEALTHY WILDLIFE POPULATIONS.
THE OUTDOOR INDUSTRY FOUNDATION
ESTIMATES THAT MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ENGAGE IN
WILDLIFE VIEWING IN SOME MANNER.
CONTRIBUTING OVER THREE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMY.
IN SOME WHETHER YOU LOOK AT IT
ECOLOGICALLY ECONOMICALLY OR
ETHICALLY ENDING FOR TRAPPING IN
CALIFORNIA IS LONG OVERDUE I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'M JUDY
MAN CREW SO SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS PROBABLY
MAINTAINED ITSELF AS A LEADER IN
COMPASSION DESPITE THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON
THAT HAS DECLARED AN ALL OUT WAR
ON WILDLIFE.
DURING A BRIEF TIME FOR MANY
SPECIES ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ARE BEING DELISTED AND TEETERING
ON THE BRINK OF EXTINCTION SUCH
AS OUR GRAY WOLVES WE MUST STAND
STRONG ON THE ANIMAL SIDE.
COMMERCIAL FOR TRAPPING IS
ECOLOGICALLY ECONOMICALLY IN AT
THE GLEE BAD POLICY ALL THE WAY
AROUND.
TRAPPING IS HORRENDOUSLY CRUEL
AS CONSUMERS ARE LEARNING VIA
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS SHOWING
TERRIFIED ANIMALS CROUCHING IN
FEAR TRYING DESPERATELY TO
ESCAPE THEIR IMMINENT FATE.
TRAPS DO NOT DISCRIMINATE SO IT
IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR TRAPPERS TO
FIND HOUSEHOLD PETS BIRDS
ENDANGERED AND RED LISTED
SPECIES AND OTHER ANIMALS DYING
OR DEAD.
TRAPPERS CALL THESE ANIMALS
TRASH KILLS BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
ECONOMIC VALUE TO THEM.
SINCE ENFORCEMENT IS NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE HERE OF ANIMALS LEFT
FOR DAYS AND THESE TRAPS CAUSING
THEM TO SUCCUMB TO EXPOSURE HEAT
FROSTBITE SHOCK ARE SLOW
STARVATION.
IF THE ANIMALS ARE STILL ALIVE
WHEN THEY ARE RETRIEVED THE
METHOD OF KILLING THEM WITHOUT
DAMAGING THEIR FERVOR IS
TYPICALLY BY WAY OF
STRANGULATION.
BEATINGS OR STOMPING THEM TO
DEATH.
THE COMMERCIAL TRAPPING PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA IS DE FACTO
TAXPAYERS SUBSIDIZE SUBSIDIZING
THE COMMERCIAL EXPLOITATION OF
NATIVE WILDLIFE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF A FEW LACKS MORAL OR FISCAL
SENSE.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN THE MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS SHOW UP TO THE
POLLS AND VOTE OVERWHELMINGLY TO
PROTECT THEM WE VALUE OUR
WILDLIFE ALIVE RATHER THAN AS
COMMODITIES TO BE KILLED SKIN.
AND SOLD PLEASE VOTE YES ON A.
B. TWO SEVENTY THREE AND PUT FOR
TRAPPING IN HISTORY BOOKS WHERE
BELONGS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND IS GLORIA.
I'LL OPEN IT UP FOR A SUPPORT.
THOSE --
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
NICHOLAS SACKETT SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN
SUPPORT.
CRYSTAL MORE LAND ON BEHALF OF
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES AND OUR MEMBERSHIP IN
SUPPORT.
WHAT I'M GOING?
TO MICHAEL GOLDBERG ON'T IN
SUPPORT AND ON BEHALF OF
COMPASSIONATE BAY IN SUPPORT.
HAULING MICHON TO HAVE THE CITY
OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
J. QUICKLY BERKELEY COALITION
FOR ANIMALS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ERIN HELGI ON
BEHALF OF PROJECT COYOTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ASHLEY AUTUMN A
RESIDENT OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS HARRISON RIBEIRO I'M
IN A RESIDENT OF OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA --
AND I SUPPORT.
JOANNE VINTON LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
ELISE FERGUSON A RESIDENT OF
MANTECA CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
MICHAEL WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
AN URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING FLOOD DOES WITH IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMALS A BAY AREA
ORGANIZATION WITH A THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
MANY OF THEM IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE JUST STRONG SUPPORT.
YEAH HI MY NAME'S COLE OR HANNAH
SOME CENTER IN SOUTH FROM SAN
JOSE CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M A SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
I DON'T KNOW SORT OF WHAT'S THIS
CHAPTER AND WE'RE OUT THERE TO
OUTRAGE EMPOWER PEOPLE TO BE
MORE COMPASSIONATE.
AND I SUPPORT THIS ONE THANK YOU.
HI ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS
KIM BOOSTER AND ON ON BEHALF OF
PROJECT HIGHER THE I SUPPORT
THIS BILL STE.
THANK YOU.
HI LINDA MIDDLE SORT OF
SACRAMENTO VEGAN SOCIETY WITH
OVER FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS RIGHT
HERE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JEFF IT'S GERALD
RESIDENT IN VOTER FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING CHINNOCK PRIDE
FROM CONNECTION EARTH STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HI I AM MANIC CARTER AND I AM
THE PRESIDENT OF CONNECTION
EARTH WE REACH OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS EVERY WEEK.
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY KINDLY.
GALEN HAZEL HARPER SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
T. C. A. DO LITTLE TOO KOJI AT
THE HEAD TO CODY'S AND CENTER OF
LOS GATOS CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LESLEY GOLDBERG DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
TAMMY YOU FROM NEARBY WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA ANNUAL COUNTY.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MIKE SAGE SANTA CLARA SUPPORT.
SAY THERE IS ANY SAN JOSE
SUPPORT.
KAREN ARE COLLINI GARDEN VALLEY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JANICE MYERS FROM GEORGETOWN
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JUDY CAR NOT SO GREAT WOULD
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CASSIE KING ON BEHALF OF DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE WITH OVER TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND PLENTY OF THEM HERE TODAY.
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ALL OF THE ANIMALS THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS IAN OR HEINOUS
EVEN THOUGH I'M NOT A CALIFORNIA
NATIVE I'LL I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE I HOPE IT'S
LIKE A STEPPING STONE.
FOR NOT JUST FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
MY HOME SAVE NEW JERSEY AND LIKE
ALL OF THE NATION AND HOPEFULLY
THE WHOLE WORLD TO BAND FOR AN
ANIMAL CRUELTY THANK YOU.
KATIE CLEARY PRESIDENT OF PEACE
FOR ANIMALS IN WORLD ANIMAL NEWS
OF LOS ANGELES I SUPPORT THIS
BILL STRONGLY.
SIMONE REYES SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA IT IS
TIME THANK YOU.
I MICHAEL DELL SAN BENITO COUNTY
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI VALERIE I AN ALOE PRESIDENT
AND CO FOUNDER OF LIEU FIVE
WOMEN FOR OUR WOMEN UNITED FOR
ANIMAL WELFARE AND I DEEPLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI ANTONIO MORE FROM SAN MATTEO
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL.
MERRIAM KAMALI FROM BELMONT
CALIFORNIA THROUGH STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
COLE HAUSER MANTECA CALIFORNIA
ANIMALS DESERVE COMPASSION NOW
THEY DESERVE EQUAL RIGHTS.
THEY THEY SHOULDN'T.
ENTER THE BRUTALITY THAT THEY'RE
ENTERING THEY NEED OUR HELP.
THANK YOU I'M IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW THEM SCAM A
RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S ALICIA SAN TORIO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M GONNA PRESTON SACRAMENTO I'M
AGAINST ANIMAL ABUSE TORTURE AND
NEGLECT I SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW THE PAID UP SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA LIFE MATTERS TO ALL
LIVING BEINGS I STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS RHIANNON WHITNEY
I'M VISITING FROM VANCOUVER
BRITISH COLUMBIA CANADA AND I
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU GUYS --
SET OF REALLY STRONG EXAMPLE FOR
THE REST OF THE WORLD SO I
REALLY.
REALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DOUG FULLER BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
BUT IT WAS STILL IN WELLS IN THE
SACRAMENTO LOCAL AND A SAX DATE
STUDENT AS A MEMBER OF THE
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE IN
BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND THAT WE LEAD THE
NATION IN COMPASSION FOR ANIMALS
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HOSTY I'M WITH DIXIE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
EVEN HAMMER WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
AND A SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WAYNE SHOWING HIM ONE
OF THE CO FOUNDERS A DIRECT
ACTION EVER WITH A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM ACTING IN SPEAKING
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
A MARCHING ANIMAL OPEN
LEGISLACIóN WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND ALL THE EFFORTS BY
THE GROUPS BEING MADE.
HI I'M JOHN CAMERON WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I LIVE IN
DUBLIN CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO WENDY BRAMBLE RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO ORGANIZER FOR THE
ANONYMOUS FOR THE VOICES CHAPTER
HERE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
I'M A SUCKER WE CLOSE.
I'M OVERWHELMING YEAH MY DREAM
COME TRUE I SUPPORT THANK.
CECILIA MARQUEZ RESIDENT OF
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
I'M JULIE WALDRON --
FROM ON THE CREEK CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT THE BILL.
VICTORIA OLSON FOR WILL IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I LIVE RIGHT NEXT ALL THESE
ANIMALS CO EXIST WITH THEM ALL
THE TIME NO PROBLEM STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL.
I'M JASON DAVIS FROM FALLS IN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI I AM ACTUALLY SPIEGELBERG.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME.
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WHERE FROM --
POLLOCK PINES CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER OTHER COUNTY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL ASK OF THOSE
WHO ARE GOING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
DO WE HAVE --
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY.
IF WILL MAKE SOME ROOM UP HERE
FOR THEM PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU. ONE OF THREE GOOD
MORNING WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MY NAME IS NANCY DANIEL I'M WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL FOR FEDERATION
FOR THE AMERICAS REGION.
AND I WANT TO CLEAR UP SOME
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT TRAPPING IN
NORTH AMERICA WHILE FOR VERY
SPECIES IT'S A VITAL TOOL FOR
WILDLIFE MANAGERS.
WHO ARE GIVEN THE AUTHORITY
THROUGH GOVERNMENT REGULATIONS
AND LAWS AND TRAPPING IS USED
FOR MANY REASONS A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW THAT WE TRAP TO
PROTECT OUR ENDANGERED SPECIES?
FOR THOSE OF YOU DO NOT KNOW THE
WHOOPING CRANE AND MANY
ENDANGERED BIRDS TO NEST ALONG
THE GREAT LAKES WOULD BE IN
DANGER TODAY IF WE WERE NOT
TRAPPING SOME OF THE THE SPECIES
THAT PREY ON THOSE.
ENDANGERED SPECIES LIKE HEIAU
DIS IN FOX'S SO WE PROTECT TO
MONITOR AND MANAGE ENDANGERED
SPECIES WE ALSO A TRAP FOR THE
RE INTRODUCTION OF SPECIES TO
THEIR ORIGINAL HABITATS. FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY THE PREVENTION OF
WILDLIFE DAMAGE TO HUMAN
PROPERTY.
THE PROTECTION OF CROPS FOR
DISEASE MANAGEMENT WE DON'T WANT.
RABIES AND DISTEMPER IN OUR
BACKYARD BASE OF SPECIES.
AND CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY THE TRAPS ARE
SELECTIVE AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF TRACK TESTING AND THE U. S.
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT THE
STATE.
THE STATE'S HAVE POURED MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO
TROPPER RESEARCH OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE SELECTIVE IN HUMANE.
THE US IS A SIGNATORY TO THE U.
S. E. U. AGREED MINUTES WHICH IS
AN INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENT --
REGULATING HUMANE TRAPPING OF
FOR BEARING SPECIES THERE'S THE
AGREEMENT ON INTERNATIONAL
HUMANE TRAPPING STANDARDS WE
HAVE TO I SO STANDARDS IN PLACE
FOR HUMANE TRAPPING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND WE ALSO HAVE BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND TRACK TESTING
FACILITY IN CANADA WHICH IS THE
STATE OF THE ART FACILITY WERE
ALL THE TRAPS ARE TESTED FOR
HUMANE S..
SO WE OPPOSE THIS BECAUSE OF THE
ABOVE MENTIONED REASONS THANK
YOU.
HI MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WE AND MANY
OF OUR MEMBERS MANAGE WATERFOWL
HABITAT.
AND WETLANDS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
BOB TRAPPING IS A VERY NECESSARY
WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT TOOL.
WHAT WHEN MANAGERS --
HAVE TO PROTECT THEIR WAY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM PASS THE
COMPROMISE SAY THE INTEGRITY OF
THE LEVEE SYSTEMS THAT.
SURROUND THOSE WETLANDS.
MANAGERS ALSO HAVE TO ADDRESS
PREDATION A WATER FOUNTAIN ASSN
BROODS --
FROM NUISANCE POPULATIONS OF
VARIOUS PEST SPECIES THESE WOULD
BE LIKE RACCOONS SKUNKS POSSUM --
MANY OF THE SPECIES THE SPECIES
ARE OVER ABUNDANT.
IN AREAS BECAUSE FRANKLY ARE
WETLAND ECOSYSTEMS NAY NO LAW
AND NATURALLY --
WE NO LONGER HAVE --
ANNUAL LARGE SCALE FLOODING SAY
UP IN THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
[inaudible]
THAT WOULD.
THE ARTICLE A COAL PREDATORS
FROM THE ECO SYSTEM.
LOCAL TRAPPERS IN RURAL AREAS --
WHO OFTEN HAVE YEARS OF
EXPERTISE AND KNOWLEDGE AND
EFFECTIVELY CONTROLLING THE
SPECIES? TO US THEY'RE VERY
VALUABLE ASSET AND SHOULD BE
PROTECTED.
AND INCLUDED IN THE WHOLE
WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT REGIME.
BUT THIS BILL BY AFFECTING WE
EFFECTIVELY REMOVING THEM --
FROM THE WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT A
QUICK EQUATION WOULD LEAVE OUT
WILDLIFE MANAGERS WITH FEWER
OPTIONS LESS FLEXIBILITY.
AND FRANKLY IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE THEIR COSTS IN MANY
WETLAND MANAGEMENT COSTS ARE
ALREADY EXCEEDINGLY HIGH.
SO YOU KNOW YOU COULD SEE SOME
WETLAND OWNERS --
HAVING A A DIFFICULTY GETTING BY
YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT.
ON THE AT THE END --
THE THE RESULTS JUST GONNA BE
FEWER CONSERVATION BENEFITS ON
THE GROUND SO WE DROP OPPOSITION
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE HEARD
FROM THE TWO WITNESSES SOMEONE
OPEN IT UP.
FOR THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO JUST
STATE YOUR NAME OR OFFICE
OPPOSING POSITION DENNIS I'LL BE
ON A OUT OF WITH THE GOVERNOR
GRAY FEW DISSOCIATION BUT I'M
ALSO PITCH HITTING TODAY BECAUSE
SHE'S DOWN PERCENT ANOTHER BILL.
FOR NO ALL CREAMERS FOR FARM
BUREAU WE'RE CONCERNED WELL
DEPRIVATION PERMITS ARE.
ARE EXEMPTED IF THERE AREN'T
SHOPPERS THAT HAVE THE SKILLS
AND THE EQUIPMENT TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT THE DECORATION FOR MANY
WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT --
TO SAVE LIVESTOCK THANK YOU.
BILL GAINES REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ROCKY
MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION IN THE
WILD SHEEP FOUNDATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA BERMAN UNDERSTATE
ARCHERY ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT SHOULD BE
DEALT WITH IN FRONT OF THE FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION BASED ON THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE.
AND IN PUBLIC FORUM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NICK VILLA CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU.
GIVE CAPITA WEST HOLLYWOOD
RESIDENT AND FOR INFORMATION
COUNTS OF AMERICA OPPOSE THIS
BILL IS A BIG NORTH THE SCIENCE
BEHIND --
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION ALLOWED LIKE
POPULATION MANAGEMENT AS
SUPPORTED BY GROUP SO YOU MIGHT
NOT EVEN THINK LIKE THANK WORLD
WILDLIFE FUND IN THE WORLD
ORGANISATION FOR ANIMAL HEALTH.
MICHAEL LELAND FOR COMMISSION
USA AYE OPPOSED BILL.
MATT GRAY ON BEHALF OF TAXPAYERS
FOR IMPROVING PUBLIC SAFETY THE
CONSERVATION BIOLOGISTS IN OUR
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE THE BILL
BASED ON THE MERITS AND SOME OF
THE STATEMENTS EARLIER WERE
FACTUALLY INCORRECT IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
OKAY.
SO YOU KNOW NOW SIR --
SPEAKING OF GOING BACK TO DíAS
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SIGNALED BLOW IT UP THIS BILL
[inaudible]
I IT'S HARD OF THE AUTHOR AND I
GET ALONG REALLY WELL IN ON THIS
ONE WE PROBABLY SEE THINGS.
A LITTLE DIFFERENT --
I WAS ALL SAD WHEN I SAW YOU ON
THIS COMMITTEE YES I KNOW IT'S
HARD -- BUT
IT'S DIFFICULT.
I THINK YOU HEARD SOME OF THE
CONTENTS.
THAT THAT ARE GENUINE I THINK
THERE IS SOME.
SOME GENUINE IS HERE TO WANTING
THIS TO SAVE.
THE BOBCATS THE COYOTES AND
EVERYTHING BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THERE ARE CERTAIN
FACTS THAT WE CAN'T IGNORE.
THESE ARE ALSO PREDATORS.
AND THEY DO FEED ON THE WILDLIFE.
AND THEY DO FEED.
ON THE BABY CALVES AND THE BABY
SHE I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE STORY.
OF A FEW YEARS BACK WHEN.
MY KIDS WERE IN FOR H. AND
SHOWING --
ANIMALS AND THEY HAD.
MY SON HAD.
CHEAP THAT WERE BEING SHOWN ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY [inaudible]
AND ONE NIGHT.
AN ATTACK OF COYOTES DECIMATED
HIS FLOCK.
I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU JUST WHAT
OCCURRED ON THAT NIGHT
[inaudible]
A FEMALE.
SINGULARLY.
CAME IN AND TOOK DOWN.
NINETEEN DAVEY LAMBS. FIVE
MOTHER USE.
WHEN I CAME OUT TO FEED AT SIX
AM IN THE MORNING?
I FOUND THE DEAD CARCASSES OF
MOST.
MANY OF THOSE BABY LAMBS.
THEIR ENTIRE FROM THE CENTER
THEIR SPINE ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
THEIR SIDE.
THEIR ENTIRE HIDE WAS DRAGGING
ON THE GROUND AND ALL YOU COULD
SEE WHERE THEIR RIBS.
THE MOTHER IS BALLING FOR THEIR
BABIES.
IT WAS VERY SURREAL AND
DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH.
BUT BEING SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN
AG.
HAD TO DO WHAT HAD TO BE DONE.
AND NOT EUTHANIZE THOSE ANIMALS
[inaudible]
THESE ANIMALS [inaudible]
WERE UNCHANGED.
AND WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
WAS REPRODUCING AT AN ESCALATED
SEPARATES.
IT'S HARD IF YOU ARE DON'T HAVE
THE TOOLS AVAILABLE TO YOU. TO
KEEP THE POPULATION GROWTH IN
CHECK.
I DON'T ADVOCATE FOR THE
ERADICATION OR THE ELIMINATION
OF ALL.
BECAUSE EACH HAS THEIR OWN
PURPOSE IN THE WORLD AS
PREDATORS TO KEEP OTHER THINGS
IN CHECK.
BUT YOU HEARD WHAT WAS HAPPENING
AROUND THE GREAT LAKES YOU'VE
HEARD IN OTHER AREAS WE HAVE IT
IN THIS STATE ARE GREAT YOU
GRATZ.
BOTH BLUE AND WHITE.
COME COMPROMISED AROUND STOCK
FUNDS WATER PONDS WATERWAYS
WHERE THEY NEST.
BY THESE VERY CREATURES THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND TAKING AWAY ALL THE TOOLS.
WILL MAKE IT INCREASINGLY MORE
DIFFICULT AND COSTLY FOR US AS A
STATE.
I THINK THERE HAS TO BE ANOTHER
WAY. FOR US TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND SOLVING THIS MAJOR PROBLEM I
DO UNDERSTAND.
THE FOR ISSUE.
THINGS CHANGED.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A WAY FOR US
TO WORK WITHOUT COMPLETELY
BANNING OR TAKING THE TOOL OFF
THE TABLE I DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS RECOGNITION.
OF THE DEPREDATION COMPONENT.
WITH AN S..
BUT IT STILL IS GOING TO MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE LANDOWNERS.
CAN'T GET ACCESS TO THE STATE OR
FEDERAL TRAPPER.
PROGRAMS AND THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW.
FISH AND WILDLIFE DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH TRAPPERS LEFT IN THE
STATE TO GO OUT AND DO THE JOB
FOR EXAMPLE A TRAPPER THAT I USE.
IT'S COMING FROM MENDOCINO
COUNTY AND HE'S ONLY THERE ON
CERTAIN DAYS.
SO IF IT'S MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR ME TO LIVE WITH SOMEBODY WHO
CAN'T CHECK THEIR TRAPS EVERYDAY
AND HUMANELY ADJUST. FOR WHAT'S
OCCURRING.
SO I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THIS.
MAYBE A LITTLE BROADER.
AND MAYBE WORK ON IT SO MAYBE.
AGAIN I'M NOT FOR LIKE A
DIFFERENT HERE AND THERE.
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
BECAUSE WE DO GET ALONG.
AND TRY TO FIND A WAY THAT WE
CAN RESOLVE THIS.
BOTH FOR THE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS.
AND THE PEOPLE ARE IN THE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE SOME OF THOSE
FOLKS.
I'M GONNA RECOGNIZE ARE BAD
ACTORS AND WE NEED [inaudible]
TO PURGE THAT.
BUT THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE ARE
VERY HUMANE AND DO THESE THINGS
AND THE RIGHTEOUS WAYS.
WE NEED TO USE ALL THE TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO US. FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE ANIMALS AND
AND FOR THE ACTIONS THAT WE HAVE
TO SAY.
SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR I THANK
YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
THIS IS --
THE BANNING OF FOR FOR
COMMERCIAL --
USING RECREATIONAL AND DOES NOT
STOP OBVIOUSLY YOU IS A LAND
OPENER YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
HAVE A TRAPPING PERMIT TO TO
PROTECT YOUR OWN PROPERTY ON
YOUR LAND --
AND AND SO I KNOW I KNOW RIGHT
NOW I UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT IS --
ALLOWING PEOPLE ON YOUR LAND TO
TO DO IT FOR COMMERCIAL PURPOSES
SOMETIMES ALLOWS YOU TO ALSO
PROTECT YOUR PROPERTY BUT THAT
IS ALSO THE STATE SUBSIDIZING
THEN -- THIS
CONTROL KIND OF SITUATION AND I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE BENEFITING FROM THAT TO
PAY FOR NOT FOR THE STATE --
BASICALLY WILDLIFE.
FUND TO BE TO BE PAYING FOR
RIGHT AND THAT THAT THAT'S WHERE
WE REALLY NEED WE CAN TALK MORE
ON THAT WE CAN WORK DEFINITELY
APPROPRIATIONS HM I I GET THAT
PART ON THE COMMERCIAL SIDE.
BUT WHAT I WOULD ALSO RECOGNIZE
IT AS THESE CREATURES ARE GIVING
THEIR LIVES MAYBE WE CAN USE.
IN SOME WAY.
THE VALUE.
OF THAT LIFE BEING GIVEN.
EVERYTHING HAS A SANCTITY.
I'VE I AGREED.
I RECOGNIZE THAT SOME PEOPLE
DON'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO WORK WITH.
ALL OF THE PARTS WE DON'T JUST
TRASH EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION FROM
VICE CHAIR.
YEAH I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
SOARED.
BECAUSE YOU WERE SAYING THAT
YOUR BILL DOESN'T PROHIBIT FOR
AT FOR INSTANCE HE W. A. --
FROM UTILIZING A TRAPPER NOW WHY
WOULD YOU SAID ONLY THE
COMMERCIAL USE THE COMMERCIAL
SALE OF HER AND RECREATIONAL
TRAPPING BUT SERVE THEIR PAIN A
TRAPPER TO COME ON TO THEIR
PROPERTY TO GUARD AGAINST PASSED
TO PROTECT THEIR PROPERTY OR
LAND YES THEY'RE ABLE TO USE
THAT.
THAT WOULD NOT BE PROHIBITED NOW
WHERE IS THAT IN THE WELL IT'S
CLEAR THIS IS OF THAT LICENSE.
FOR THERE'S OTHER TRAPPING
PERMITS.
FISHING GAME CODE FORTY ONE
POINT EIGHT ZERO AND FORTY ONE
FIVE TWO SO THOSE THAT HAVE A
LICENSE TO USE THAN SELL THE FOR
THAT THEY CAN'T BE HAVE THE CELL
I CAN'T HAVE A LICENSED ITSELF --
ANYMORE THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
OPERATE --
FOR TRAPPING FOR FOR PROTECTION
OF PROPERTY FOR AYE INVASIVE
SPECIES CONTROLLED HAS CONTROL
RIGHT BUT I MEAN THAT AND I
THINK THATTHAT IS.
ULTIMATELY WHAT'S PART OF IT
RIGHT IS LOOK I MEAN OUT I DON'T
WEAR FOR YEAH BUT I THINK
PROBABLY A LOT OF PEOPLE DOWN
RIGHT BUT YEAH BUT THERE IS
THERE IS A MARKET FOR THAT AND
IT'S WHAT MAKES THIS.
AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE TO COME OUT
AND DO THE DEPREDATION THAT WE
KNOW.
DOES NEED TO GET DONE RIGHT AND
RIGHT NOW AS AS YOU KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW POINTED
OUT IF YOU HAVE TO WAIT ON A
FEDERAL TRAPPERS SOMEBODY TO
COME.
IT COULD BE. TOO LATE FRIDAY IN
THE CASE OF YOUR LIVE STOCK THE
YOU'RE TRYING TO PROTECT WELL
THERE WOULD BE NOTHING TO
PREVENT THE SAME PERSON TO ADD
MAKE MONEY BEING A PEST CONTROL.
TRAPPER IN YOUR AREA THEY COULD
HAVE A DIFFERENT LICENSE SO YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT
NECESSARILY MAYBE CREATES A NEW
MARKET FOR FOR NEW JOBS --
THAT ARE IN LINE AND AND ARE
LESS LIKELY TO HAVE THINGS LIKE
INCIDENTAL TAKEN YOU KNOW.
BASICALLY --
FOR TRAPPING FOR RECREATION XIN
FOR PROTECTION OF PUBLIC --
INFRASTRUCTURE SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE HAVE
THE NUTRIA RAT THAT IS THE NEW
TALK ABOUT A LOT OF THAT A LOT
RIGHT.
IT'S AN INVASIVE SPECIES RIGHT
SO WOULD WE BE ABLE TO TRAP AND
I MEAN AND ULTIMATELY IN MANY
CASES KILL THAT ANIMAL I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S PART
WHILE LIKE MANAGEMENT THAT'S NOT
PREVENTED IN THIS BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU CAN'T THEN GO SELL THE FOR
OF THE NUTRIA I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A MARKET FOR IT ALL
RIGHT YOU KNOW.
THAT THAT'S WHAT THIS PREVENTS
BUT I MEAN MAYBE THERE'S MARKET
SOMEWHERE THAT CAN BE CONSIDERED
RECREATION.
THAT'S NOT RECREATIONAL THAT'S
WILDLIFE PROTECTION PROPERTY
PROTECTION ALL THESE THINGS HAVE
HAVE DIFFERENTTRAPPING LICENSES
WELL MAYBE I'LL GO TO MISTER
HENLEY DISSENTS HE'S IN THE
SPACE OF PROTECTING WHAT LATEST
WOULD YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
WELL JUST TO CLARIFY WE ARE NOT
COVERED UNDER THE AGRICULTURE OR
PRIVATE PROPERTY.
EXEMPTION IN ALL CASES --
AND THEN WHEN WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH PREDATORS OF WILDLIFE YOU
KNOW THAT IS A WHOLE SEPARATE
ISSUE.
BY YOU THEN TAKING TOOLS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN USING THESE LOCAL
TRAPPERS TO TRAP.
EITHER FOR THE FOR OR
RECREATIONALLY TAKE THAT TO AWAY
FROM US THEN IT'S GONNA BE
HARDER FOR US THAN.
TO ACCOMPLISH OUR WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT GOALS AND SO THAT'S
THE ISSUE FOR US SURE I I THINK
YOU NEED TO ADDRESS TO THE
COMMITTEE NOT ME BUT BUT IN IN.
THAT THAT OFFER IS AN OUTLINE IT
SO I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THAT
NOTHING IN THIS BILL.
PREVENTS THAT FROM HAPPENING WE
CAN HAVE A SEPARATE AND FULLER
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE WHAT
THE COST BECOMES AND THEN IT'S
REALLY JUST A TRANSFER COSTS IN
AND NOT SOMETHING I THINK IT'S
AN APPROPRIATE DISCUSSION AS AS
TERM VICE CHAIR PREPARATIONS WE
CAN HAVE IT.
IS WHERE'S THE COST BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SUBSIDIZING
THESE THESE PERMITS AND SO.
AT I UNDERSTAND THIS BILL DOES
NOT OUTLAW.
AT THAT THAT TAKING THAT
TRAPPING OF OF INVASIVE SPECIES
WHAT ABOUT THE PUBLIC HAVE
BENEFITS OF THE TRACK HAVE ABOUT
THAT NEED VICE CHAIR.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ALL
THIS I I'LL TO SOMEONE I MEAN I
I THINK WITH THIS HIGHLIGHTS IS
THAT THERE ARE STILL ISSUES AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR SAYING HEY
LOOK WE BEEN OBVIOUSLY MYSELF
THE MEASURE BIGELOW I THINK IT
WORK ON COMING FROM A RURAL AREA
UNDERSTANDING THE AGRICULTURAL.
IMPACTS AND YOU KNOW FOR THE
WILD AND HABITAT THAT IS IN A
LOT OF OUR DISTRICTS --
WOULD APPRECIATE WORKING THROUGH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES I THINK ARE
A ARE POTENTIAL CONFLICT AND
MAKING HARDER.
SOMETIMES DOES MAKE IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE RAY AND THAT'S I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE CONCERNS
IS THAT IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
CARRY OUT WHAT OUR ROUTINE.
PROTECTION YOU KNOW PART OF THE
ROUTINE AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES
ON MANY.
FARMS AND RANCHES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT COULD BE PROBLEMATIC
SO THAT'S JUST THAT'S WHERE I'M
COMING FROM AND I CAN'T SUPPORT
IT RIGHT YET TODAY BUT I WOULD
LIKE.
TO CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION WE
DO HAVE A MOTION THREE MEN OF
SECOND BY MISS GLORIA.
DR.
I THANK THE CHAIR I HAVE A
QUESTION NOT OUR CUP REMEMBERS
SO ADDRESSED THE ISSUES IN THE A
RURAL AREA I COME FROM URBAN
AREA SELECT A CITY SELF --
BY WE HAD TO DEAL WITH THE
INVASION OF WHAT COYOTES SO INTO
RESIDENTIAL AREAS AND YOU CANNOT
USE OUR RIFLES TO WHATEVER TO
CONTROL THEM AND COMMON TOOL IS
SO TRAPPING.
AND THE FULL RELOCATION PURPOSES
CELL AND IN THOSE CASES SO HOW
DO YOU DISTINGUISH A WHAT DO YOU
MAKE AN EXEMPTION.
THAT THE EXEMPTION EXIST THIS
ISN'T BANNING THAT THIS ONLY
BANS THE THE TRAPPING FOR THE
SALE OF FOR OR RECREATION THAT
DOESN'T FALL INTO THAT PERMIT.
YOU JUST SPECIFIED IT IT'S TO
REMOVE A COYOTE FROM AN URBAN
AREA THAT'S NOT CHANGED BY THIS
BILL.
I WANT TO REPEAT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT TAKES AWAY THE THE
LICENSE BY WHICH PEOPLE USE THAT
TO SELL FOR OR TO TRAP FOR
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES WHICH I
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT IS BUT BUT IT'S IT'S THE
SAILOR FOR IT DOESN'T STOP.
ANY OF THE PROVISIONS BY WHICH
WERE PROTECTING PERSONAL
PROPERTY OR LIVES AGRICULTURE --
ENVY I'VE AGAINST INVASIVE
SPECIES A WHOLE HOST OF VALID
REASONS WHY WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO TRAP ANIMALS IT DOESN'T
CHANGE ANY OF THAT CLEAR TO ME --
THANKS.
FOR NO OTHER QUESTIONS WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND SELECT
CLOSE.
RECESS ASSN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SEARCH I POSSIBLE ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CHOI NO CHOI
NO.
CHIU [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY NO.
FRIEDMAN.
HI FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
WOULD.
WOULD I IT WILL BE A CALL OPEN
ON THAT ITEM THANK YOU.
THE P..
FORTY FOUR SO REMEMBER FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
MORNING.
MORNING BILL DOES ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH THE TWO
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
TO PROPOSE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT
TO THE TOP OF PAGE.
FIVE WITH REGARDS TO A MOMENT
NUMBER ONE I WE DO BUILD SOME
CONCERN FOR THE LANGUAGE BUT
LIKE TO KEEP WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON TIGHTENING THE
LANGUAGE I TO NARROW THE
EXEMPTIONS THAT IT'S LIMITED
PERHAPS TO SKINS TAKEN WITH THE
BALLOT CALIFORNIA HUNTING
LICENSE.
BOOK LIKE THAT THAT OPTION.
I AB FORTY FOUR WOULD MAKE IT
UNLAWFUL TO GIVE SELLER
MANUFACTURE A NEW FOR PRODUCT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IF PASSED CALIFORNIA WILL BE THE
FIRST STATE IN THE COUNTRY TO
BAN THE CRUEL AND UNNECESSARY
FOR TRADE WITHIN ITS BOUNDARIES.
FOR IS NOT A BY PRODUCT OF THE
MEAT INDUSTRY AND I REPEAT THE
FOR THAT IS PURCHASED IN A
FURRIER IS NOT THE BY PRODUCT OF
THE MEAT INDUSTRY IT COMES FROM
ANIMALS THAT ARE FACTORY FARMED
OR TRAPPED PURELY FOR FASHION.
FOR FARMING AND THE FOR TRADE
ARE LARGELY SELF REGULATED.
IN THE US I WAS VERY SURPRISED
LOS PROVIDING PROTECTION FOR
ANIMALS HELD ON THESE FARMS AND
FOR URBAN AND ANIMALS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO HUMANE SLAUGHTER
RULES THE WAY THAT ANIMALS --
SLAUGHTERED FOR FOR FOR FOOD ARE.
TODAY THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
HUMANE AND VERY CHIC
ALTERNATIVES IN TERMS OF PH
R THAT'S RITUALLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM REAL.
FOR AN ALTERNATIVE TEXTILES THAT
ARE JUST AS WARM AND JUSTICE
FASHIONABLE.
COMPANIES AROUND THE WORLD OR
FUELING INNOVATION AND NEW AND
SUSTAINABLE FABRICS AND A LOT OF
OUR MAJOR FASHION MANUFACTURERS
HAVE ALREADY GOTTEN THE MESSAGE
ABOUT CRUELTY FREE PRODUCTS AND
THE DESIRABILITY OF THEM.
RETAILERS SUCH AS GUCCI MICHAEL
KORS JIMMY CHOO ARMANI BURBERRY
AND SHOULD NOW HAVE MADE THE
DECISION TO GO FOR FREE.
SEVERAL CITIES INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES WEST --
WEST HOLLYWOOD TO SAN FRANCISCO
AND BERKLEY HAVE ALREADY TAKEN A
STAND BY PASSING ORDINANCES
MAKING IT ILLEGAL TO SELL TRADE
OR MANUFACTURE FOR WITHIN THEIR
BOUNDARIES.
AND TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES
NOT AFFECT LEATHER SHEEP FOR AND
CAL FOR ANIMALS THAT ARE
HARVESTED FOR THEIR FOR FOOD AND
WE WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THAT
MIGHT PHILOSOPHY IS THAT IF YOU
ARE TAKING ANIMAL FOR FOOD YOU
SHOULD USE EVERY BIT OF THAT
ANIMAL.
SO WE WERE VERY CLEAR TWO EXAMS --
THOSE ANIMALS WE ARE NOT --
CONTROLLING LEATHER AND
SHEARLING.
AB FORTY FOUR SUPPORTED BY HUGO
BY STELLA MCCARTNEY SUSIE AND
JACK WELCH MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
FROM LOS ANGELES AND OVER SIXTY
OTHER DESIGNERS RETAILERS IN
ORGANIZATIONS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FOUR IS PJ
SMITH WITH THE HUMANE SOCIETY
MARCHING FOUNDER OF ANIMAL
HOPING LEGISLATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
HELLO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS PJ SMITH AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF FASHION POLICY FOR
THE HUMANE SOCIETY THE UNITED
STATES A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB.
FORTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMANE SOCIETY KNIGHTED STATES
AND OUR MANY SUPPORTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
WE THINK WE LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY WOMAN A FRIEDMAN
FRAZIER DO SEEN AS HISTORIC
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WHICH IF
PASSED WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA THE
FIRST STATE TO BAN THE CRUEL AND
UNNECESSARY FOR TRADE. FOR THE
PAST DECADE I WORK WITH DOZENS
OF THE TOP OF PERIL COMPANIES TO
CREATE POLICIES THEY'RE GOOD FOR
ANIMALS AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
FROM LUXURY BRANDS LIKE GUCCI
CHANEL BERBERIAN MICHAEL CORES
TO RETAILERS LIKE TJ MAX AND
BURLINGTON COAT FACTORY.
WHEN THESE COMPANIES DO THEIR
HOMEWORK AND ACTUALLY EXAMINE
THE FUR TRADE CLOSELY EVERY
MARKETING SCHEME EVERY VEGA
CLAIM AND EVERY CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM THEY QUICKLY REALIZE
THERE'S NO WAY TO HUMANELY
SOURCE?
FOR SADLY THE FUR INDUSTRY
CONTINUES TO TRY TO GREEN LOST
ITS TRADE WITH DIFFERENT
INDUSTRY FUNDED MARKETING
SCHEMES.
BUT THANKFULLY TOP FASHION
BRANDS EVEN THE ONES THAT SOLD
FOR OUR SEEN RIGHT THROUGH THE
SCHEMES AND ARE CHOOSING TO GO
FOR FREE SINCE THEY FAIL TO
ADDRESS.
THIS SERIOUS ANIMAL WELFARE
PROBLEMS INHERENT WITH CONFINING
AND ON DOMESTICATED ANIMAL AND A
SMALL PARING CAGE FOR ITS ENTIRE
LIFE.
DEATH BY ANAL ANAL ELECTROCUTION
OR GASSING IS STANDARD ON FOR
FACTORY FARMS.
AS WELL ANIMALS INCLUDING
THREATENED SPECIES AND EVEN OUR
PETS ARE CALL IN AN
INDISCRIMINATE LEG HOLD TRAPS
FOR DAYS WITHOUT FOOD OR WATER
IT'S ACCEPTED NORM.
NUMEROUS INVESTIGATIONS HAVE
SHOWN THAT CERTIFIED FARMS ARE
STILL RAMPANT WITH SELF
MUTILATION.
INJURIES BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
THAT CARE IN FOX'S THAT ARE BRED
TO HAVE SO MUCH SKIN THEY ARE NO
LONGER ABLE TO MOVE PROPERLY.
TODAY CONSUMERS CARE ABOUT
ANIMAL WELFARE ANY IN INNOVATION
MORE THAN EVER AND FASHION
BRANDS ARE RESPONDING TO THIS
GROWING MARKET BY ANNOUNCING FOR
FREE POLICIES.
WHEN ONLINE LUXURY RETAILER NOW
TO PORT DAY FIRST CONCERT FIRST
CONSIDER GOING FOR FREE IT
SURVEYED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND OF
ITS CUSTOMERS INCLUDING THOSE
THAT SPEND OVER MILLION DOLLARS
ON ITS SITE EVERY YEAR?
AND THEY OVERWHELMINGLY ASKED
THE COMPANY TO GO FOR FREE.
NOW FASHION COMPANIES LEFT AND
RIGHT ARE REJECTING THE FOR
INDUSTRIES DISINGENUOUS ATTEMPTS
TO MARKET FOR AS HUMANE.
AND REALIZE THE COMPUTER COMPANY
OUR CONSUMERS WANT NOTHING TO DO
WITH ANIMAL CRUELTY IN THEIR
CLOTHING CHOICES.
THIS IS LED TO AN ONSLAUGHT OF
JUST IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CHANEL BURBERRY VERSACE DINESEN
FURSTENBERG DONNA KAREN COACH
INSTYLE MAGAZINE.
FARFETCH TJ MAX IN COLUMBIA
SPORTSWEAR AND NOW IT'S FOR FREE
POLICIES. THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT
WAS GUCCI MICHAEL COURTS YOU
CANNOT AFFORD TODAY JIMMY CHOO
BURLINGTON COAT FACTORY IN THE
NORTH FACE AND BEFORE THAT WAS
OUR MONEY RALPH AROUND TOMMY
HILFIGER.
CALVIN KLEIN HUGO BOSS STELLA
MCCARTNEY AND DOZENS OF OTHERS.
THIS MASS EXODUS ONLY SPEEDING
UP AS MORE COMPANIES PLEDGE NO
LONGER SELL FOR MORE COUNTRIES
LIKE UNITED KINGDOM NORWAY AND
THE NETHERLANDS BAND FOR
PRODUCTION.
AND MORE CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO BAND FOR SALES
THIS IS BRINGING INNOVATIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE ALTERNATIVES TO TAKE
ITS PLACE.
RIGHT NOW FASHION BRANDS ARE
WORKING WITH FLOW PHùFOR
COMPANIES TO CREATE
BIODEGRADABLE MATERIALS THAT THE
SAME LOOK AND FEEL IS FOR BUT
WITHOUT THE CRUELTY MASK IF YOU
GET SUMMARIZED AS A STILL AS A
STATE THAT'S NOTE FOR INNOVATION
CALIFORNIA THE GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
CAPITALIZE ON THIS GROWING
MARKET AS WELL AS IT SOLIDIFY
ITS POSITION AS THE MOST HUMANE
STATE IN THE NATION THANK YOU
THANK YOUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HE TOOK MOST OF YOUR TIME OFF
SHORE.
NO THAT'S OKAY HI MY NAME IS
MARK FROM ANIMAL OPEN
LEGISLACIóN I'M ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL ON I LIKE
TO THANK LAURA FOR BEING SUCH A
AMAZING SPONSOR AND SOCIAL
DESCENT.
CALIFORNIA BEING THE MOST HUMANE
STATE. FOR IN THE CRUEL WAY
ANIMALS ARE IN HUMANE EXPLOITED
FOR THEIR SKIN SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT
OF THE FOR INDUSTRY CLAIM THAT
FOR IS HUMANE.
AND THAT MUCH OF WHAT IS SEEN IN
REGARDS TO THE VIDEOS THAT ARE
SHARED ON SOCIAL MEDIA ARE FAKE
ARE OUTDATED.
PART OF WHAT.
OUR HISTORY HAS BEEN IN OUR
GROUP IS THAT WE'VE GONE INTO
FOR FARMS THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES CANADA FINLAND
[inaudible]
AND CHINA.
EARLIER TODAY I HEARD A STORY OF
A LAMB.
AND ITS SUFFERING AND HOW HARD
IT WAS TO SEE THAT AND HOW SAD
AND HOW.
GUT WRENCHING.
I HAVE WALKED THOSE SAME TYPE OF
THINGS IN FOR FARMS WHERE.
THERE THE SMALL CAGES THAT THEIR
BREAD AND AND NEVER TOUCH GROUND
EVER.
AND NOT JUST THAT THEY ARE.
STUNDEN ELECTROCUTED IN MAINE.
BUT THE WORST PART OF IT IS EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE NOT TRYING.
TO MANY OF THESE FOXES ARE STILL
ALIVE AT THE END.
HANGING FROM THESE FOLKS WERE
THEY RIP THEIR SKIN OFF AND YOU
CAN HEAR THEM SCREAMING.
THERE IS NO WAY TO REGULATE THAT.
REGULATION OF THE FOR INDUSTRY
AND CALIFORNIA BEING THE HUMANE
STATED IS.
IT IS 1100% IMPOSSIBLE TO DO
THAT.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT CRUELTY IT'S
ABOUT ETHICS AND IT'S ABOUT
PUTTING COMPASSION FIRST.
ASK CALIFORNIANS.
BEING IN AN ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE YOU GET TO WITNESS THESE
THINGS?
THERE IS NO SUFFERING GREATER
THAN THAT.
OF SOMETHING OR SOMEONE THAT YOU
CANNOT HELP WHERE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT IT.
I ASK THAT YOU IMAGINE YOUR OWN
CHILDREN.
OR SOMEONE YOU LOVE BUT YOUR
FRIENDS AND YOUR FAMILY.
IMAGINE BEING ENSLAVED AND BEING
THAT REYES AND WATCHING EVERY
DAY THAT SUFFERING.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL STANDS
AGAINST AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE.
FOR ETHICS A PASSION MORALITY
AND THERE IS NO.
NO WAY TO REGULATE AN INDUSTRY
LIKE THAT AND WE ASK YOU FOR
YOUR YES VOTES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL OPEN IT UP FOR OTHERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
FOR THE MEASURE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION.
NICHOLAS SACKETT SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT GIVE.
AGAIN A CALL OR HANNAH SO
SENATOR OUTSIDE THE CLARA COUNTY
I KNOW I'M SORT OF VOICELESS
ANYWHERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BECAUSE THERE'S ALWAYS A WAY TO
LIVE LIFE WITHOUT HARMING OTHERS
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THAT A COUPLE SIZE
OF THE ROOM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IT'S NO MORE LIMIT THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERSHIP WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MICHAEL GOLDBERG ALSO READ --
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
COMPASSIONATE DAY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRUEL AND INHUMANE TO
LET THIS FOR INDUSTRY CONTINUE
THE SALE OF FOR MUST BE BANNED
THAT SAN FRANCISCO THANK YOU.
THEY HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME ANDREAS SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HOLLOW CENTER OEO FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF D. X. SEE
VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
LESLEY GOLDBERG EL SERENO
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT I'M
REPRESENTING COMPASSIONATE BAY.
I'M DIANE AN AVON FROM BERKELEY
I REPRESENT DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE.
AND I HAVE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
ALEX ON TORIO. 4% IN DIXIE
FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA YES.
SHEILA MILLER RESIDENT OF EL
GRANADA CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
THE X. CA I ASKED YOU FOR YOUR
COMPASSION AND EMPATHY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MATTHEW MCKENNA OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN ERIN HOW HE
ON BEHALF OF PROJECT COYOTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
SEND EMAIL DXC AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU.
CORRIE ROWLAND BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS.
HI AGAIN KATIE CLEARY PRESIDENT
OF PEACE FOR ANIMALS IN WORLD
ANIMAL NEWS AN EXECUTIVE
PRODUCER OF GIVE ME SHELTER ON
NETFLIX WHERE WE HIGHLIGHTED
THIS ISSUE.
AND WE SHOWED --
WHAT HAPPENED --
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI AM BOBBY SAID FROM LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF LA ANIMAL
SAVING WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI KATIE BROWN FROM LANCASTER
CALIFORNIA AND NUMBER OF DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS.
MATTHEW HAMIDI ON BEHALF OF IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMALS AND IT'S TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MEGAN STEIN BURKE RESIDENT OF
BERKELEY --
I AM WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI AM CASSIE KING I'M A RESIDENT
OF BERKELEY AN ORGANIZER OF
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE.
AND FROM MYSELF AND MY BUNNY AT
HOME WHO IS RESCUED FROM
SLAUGHTER.
I WOULD URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL FOR ALL OF THOSE ANIMALS
THANK YOU.
IN THE MIDDLE FOR SACRAMENTO
VEGAN SOCIETY WITH OVER FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS SUPPORTS THIS
BILL AS WELL AS I'M A MEMBER OF
THE XC THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ISSUED A HOT DAY
I'M PART OF THE BERKELEY CHAPTER
FOR DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND PROTECTING ALL LIVING
BEINGS THANK YOU.
AS I SAID EARLIER MY NAME IS IAN
ARE YOU HEN S. AND I'M VISITING
FROM NEW JERSEY AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SO THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL SERVE AS A MODEL
STATE FOR HOW TO PROPERLY TREAT
AND WITH NO CRUELTY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUBTLY AMERICA FROM
TOKYO JAPAN AND ON BEHALF OF ALL
THEIR FRIENDS IN --
FOR IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HER FRIEDMAN DIRECTOR OF
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND IS A
BELIEVER IN COMPASSION I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY BREWSTER
I'M FROM SANTA CLARA AND ON
BEHALF OF PROJECT COYOTE A VOTE
YES ON SUPPORT FOR COMPASSION
THANK YOU.
JUDY WINDOW FROM MARIN COUNTY
CINEMA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE SPELL.
ANNA HORNING FROM SAN MATTEO
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
JACOBY MARINO --
DATE OF SACRAMENTO STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HI AM SHY AND DANNER RESIDENT OF
SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA AND I'M
WITH DIXIE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI THERE MY NAME'S DAWSON COLE
I'M AN ORGANIZER FOR THE SAVE
MOVEMENT AND FOR DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
LISA CARLIN FOR WESTLAKE VILLAGE
CALIFORNIA AND REPRESENTING
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MARK LUCAS SACRAMENTO VEGAN
SOCIETY AND DIRECT ACTION STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO AGAIN WENDY BRAMBLE
ORGANIZER FOR NON IS FOR THE
VOICE OF SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT THINKING.
HI JUDY MANN COUP SO AGAIN
SOCIAL COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
HI VALERIE EN EL I AM STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS WELL
THANK YOU.
J. QUICKLY BERKELEY COALITION
FOR ANIMALS ASKING YOU TO MAKE
HISTORY WITH AN AYE VOTE.
OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN SUPPORT
HI CINDER CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS GRADUATE
IS NOT A CONSERVATION EFFORT.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MATTHEW DEMPSEY SAN FRANCISCO
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
ALICIA CENTURIA SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA I'M WITH THE SAVE
MOVEMENT IN DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
PRESS THE HONEY RESIDENT
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND ORGANIZE
WERE DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR THE
BILLIONS OF ANIMALS HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVES.
YOU KNOW THE PAID A SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA WITH SACRAMENTO VEGAN
SOCIETY AND THE ACTUALLY AND US
AIRFORCE VETERAN I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A
WITH THE TRUST FOR POP UP PUBLIC
LAND THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN SORRY
FOR THE LATE SUPPORT BUT NONE
THE LESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL.
MOLLY COLTON SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
AN URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
FOR I AM NOT IN A PLANE FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I'M WITH DIXIE
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL LET'S MAKE FOR HISTORY.
I'M TONY MORE FROM SAN MATTEO
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL AND JUST WANT TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT YOU CAN WEAR
VERY STYLISH WARM CLOTHING THAT
NO AND SUFFERED.
FOR JOHN FROM MEYER FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
MAKING CALIFORNIA LEADER AND
COMPASSION.
I'M GOOD ENOUGH YOUR FROM WORK
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA WITH THE
REDUCTION EVERYWHERE IN A
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I'M KAREN OCT ALLENI AGAIN FROM
GARDEN VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO LEAD THE NATION AND
YOU MAIN PRACTICES FOR ANIMALS
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI AND JANICE MYERS FROM
GEORGETOWN CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JUDY KERN ALSO FROM GREENWOOD
CALIFORNIA EL DORADO COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MERRIAM KAMALI FROM BELMONT SAM
SO COUNTY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I'M LUIS BERNIE A I'M AN
INVESTIGATOR WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I SUPPORT AB
FORTY FOUR FOR ALL THE ANIMALS
I'VE MET INSIDE FOR FARMS.
MY NAME IS THOMAS CHIANG FROM
SOME CISCO.
REPRESENTING DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND ANONYMOUS FOR THE
VOICES IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
BI FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S DAN SHOW I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE XC I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB.
FORTY FOR AN EMPLOYEE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING IN SUPPORT AS WELL.
MY NAME'S EVA HAMMER I'M A
RESIDENT OF BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
AN ORGANIZER WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE ENERGY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MICHAEL DELL RESIDENTS SAN
BENITO COUNTY AND A MEMBER OF
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE
STRONGLY.
SEE YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CECILIA MARK HAS OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA A STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BALFE.
DILLON WELLS STUDENTS SOCCER
STATE UNIVERSITY PLEASE LET US
LEAD THE NATION IN COMPASSION
RATHER THAN INTEREST IN INDUSTRY
PROFIT THANK YOU.
I'M HAS SEE I'M FROM SACRAMENTO --
WITH DIRECT DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL WE NEED TO PUT
COMPASSION FOR ALL LIVING BEINGS
ON THIS PLANET THANK YOU.
DEBORAH CLASS AND I'M HERE FROM
THE BOTTLE FOR ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF MY BUNNY MOBY WHO WILL
NOT BE HAVING HIS SKIN REMOVED
IN ORDER TO LINE A PAIR OF
GLOVES A RELEASE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAELIN HAZEL OFFER FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I'M DONNA PRESTON AND IMPROVE
WELL FROM SAN DIEGO I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO NOW.
AND I AM STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
FORTY FOUR I'M WITH SACRAMENTO
ANIMAL RIGHTS I'M WITH SEGMENT
OF IN SOCIETY OVER FOUR THOUSAND
MEMBERS.
SO MANY PEOPLE COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
FOR HI.
NICOLE HAUSER FROM MANTECA
CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU ALL HAVE --
PETS AT HOME I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND YOU THAT.
THEY DESERVE THE LOVE AND
COMPASSION AND MAYBE THEY CAN
HELP YOU RELATE.
I'M TO THE OTHER ANIMALS THAT
AREN'T PADS A SISTERLY BUT ALL
ANIMALS DESERVE COMPASSION SO
PLEASE FIND IN YOUR HEARTS TODAY
TO PROTECT THEM.
THANK YOU.
LET'S KEEP CALIFORNIA.
TAMMY YOU FROM WITHIN A YOLO
COUNTY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
MIKE SAGE SANTA CLARA SUPPORT.
SAY THAT IS VERY SAN JOSE
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING HE'S YOU DO LITTLE
WITH TO CODY'S AND CENTER OF LOS
GATOS.
THE PUBLIC KNOWS THAT FOR IS
SYNONYMOUS WITH TORTURE AND IT'S
ON ITS WAY OUT STILL LET'S BE
THE FIRST STATE TO BAN IT THANK
YOU.
HI AM KITTY JONES BERKELEY --
REPRESENTING DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE.
I SUPPORT THIS MAKE FOR HIS
STATE.
WHEN SHOWING ALSO FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE THE XP?
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO DO
THE SAME THANK YOU.
MORNING MY NAME IS JASON DAVIS
FROM FALLS IN CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JOHN CAMERON FROM
DUBLIN CALIFORNIA.
AND I ANYBODY THAT WOULD BE
AGAINST THIS BILL.
I WOULD.
JUST ASK THEM IF THEY COULD DO
ONE DAY PICTURE YOURSELF.
IN ONE OF THESE CAGES JUST FOR
ONE DAY.
AND EVEN PEOPLE IN THE FOR
INDUSTRY WHO SUPPORT THIS WHOLE
HEARTEDLY WOULD CHANGE THEIR
MIND IN A HEART BEAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JAY FITZGERALD FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH IN YOUR NAME OR THEY
CAN.
ELISE FERGUSON RESIDENT A MAN TO
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JIM CHEN SOLD I'M
WITH THE POP PROJECT AND A NON
PROFIT I'M FROM LOS ANGELES I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S HAIR'S INNER
BARROW --
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA BY LIVE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DOUG FULLER DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE TO MAKE COMPASSION
THE FASHION SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AMIR TANNER I'M FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME'S ANASTASIA MEL I'M
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I'M
STRONGLY SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
HI I'M RACHEL ZIGGLER FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL I HOPE YOU
WILL.
TOO PICTORIALS SAID RESIDENT OF
A WILL IN CALIFORNIA.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OVERDUE CAN'T
BELIEVE WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
IT.
RHIANNON WHITNEY OF VANCOUVER
BRITISH COLUMBIA CANADA I AGREE
WITH WHAT SHE AND EVERYBODY ELSE
IS SAYING THIS IS SUCH AN
ARCHAIC PRACTICE.
IT'S SO OUTDATED IT SO CRUEL
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO REASON A
SPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
YOU GUYS HAVE A NICE CLIMB I
LIVE IN CANADA I DON'T WEAR.
FOR IT'S FREEZING COLD UP THERE
THIS IS JUST.
TOTAL SUPPORT TOTAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WAS SHOCKER INTO I WAS
ASKED BY MY COLLEAGUE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI THANK YOU.
I'M JULIE WALDRON REPRESENTING
COMPASSIONATE BAY AND D. EXCEED
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BLOOD DOES WITH IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS --
AND ALSO REST IN OFF MARIN
COUNTY -- IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
REMINDING YOU THAT --
DOZENS OF COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE ALREADY LEFT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MASK --
THOSE WERE GOING TO BE THAT'S
FINE OPPOSITION A BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD IF THERE'S
ANYONE.
MOVE THOSE OTHERS MOTION.
MOTION BY MISTER KALRA SECOND BY
MISTER GLORIA.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEITH
KAPLAN I'M A RESIDENT WEST
HOLLYWOOD FOR THIRTY YEARS AND I
AM WITH THE FOR INFORMATION
COUNTS OF AMERICA THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
WHERE WHERE THE HSUS STUDIES
THAT YOU'VE SEEN THEIR AN
ACCURATE THEIR OUTDATED A DECADE
OLD?
AND IF YOU SAW WOMEN'S WEAR
DAILY LAST WEEK THEY'VE EXPOSING
A BEST A GEISHA BUT THIS GETTING
A LIVE VIDEO WAS BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR A SNUFF FILM TO CREATE A
NARRATIVE.
ANIMAL RIGHTS GROUPS HAVE NOT
PRESENTED YOU WITH THE FAX WE
WELCOME THE CHANCE TO SIT DOWN
AND TALK.
WE SHARE YOUR CONCERN FOR ANIMAL
WELFARE AND WE WORKED VIGOROUSLY
TOWARDS IMPROVING ANIMAL WELFARE
PRACTICES BASED ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY.
GIVE US A CHANCE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT IT.
AB FORTY FOUR HAS PRESENTED A
GOOD STARTING POINT FOR US TO
WORK TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPLEMENT MEANINGFUL PROGRAMS.
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES ON A
GLOBAL SCALE BUT A BAND IS NOT
THE ANSWER.
AND WE HùTHE BAND PROMPTED
RETAILS AND CUSTOMERS TO GO TO
BEVERLY HILLS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO RETAILERS ARE
PLANNING OUTPOSTS IN PALO ALTO.
A BAND WILL SIMPLY SEND
CONSUMERS OUT OF QUE JUST.
FOR CALIFORNIA LOSES JOBS
CALIFORNIA LOSES TAX REVENUES
AND IN THE END THE BAN ITSELF
HAS LITTLE IMPACT ON ANIMAL
WELFARE.
BUT WHAT A BAND WILL DO IS TAKE
AWAY CONSUMERS RIGHT TO CHOOSE
YOU WILL TAKE AWAY THEIR RIGHT
TO PURCHASE A NATURAL RENEWABLE
AND SUSTAINABLE PRODUCT LIKE
NATURAL.
FOR LEAVING THEM ONLY SYNTHETIC
FIBERS THAT VIOLATE THE VERY
CORE VALUES OF SUSTAINABILITY.
PRODUCTS LIKE FAKE FURTHER
PETROLEUM BASED NON
BIODEGRADABLE AND IMPOSE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT SO REAL
THAT EVEN HERE IN YOUR OWN
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
HAS RECOGNIZED THIS THREAT WITH
THE INTRODUCTION OF A MICROFIBER
BELL.
SO LET'S ALL PAUSE TAKE THE TIME
TO EDUCATE OURSELVES AND TALK TO
EACH OTHER AND WORKING TOGETHER
LET'S MAKE THE BEST DECISIONS TO
MEET THE OBJECTIVES OF IMPROVING
ANIMAL WELFARE IN IS IMPACTFUL
AND BROUGHT AWAY AS POSSIBLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NANCY DANIEL IN THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL FOR FEDERATION FOR
THE AMERICAS REGION.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THANK MISS
FRIEDMAN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS DIALOGUE AND
ALTHOUGH WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB
FORTY FOUR WE DO WANT TO WORK
WITH YOU ON ALTERNATIVE.
AND OUR ALTERNATIVE WILL HAVE
REAL AND MEANINGFUL IMPACTS ON
GLOBAL ANIMAL WELFARE STANDARDS.
THE ALTERNATIVE IS CALLED FOR
MARK A BRAND NEW GLOBAL PROGRAM
THAT WILL ENSURE HIGH ANIMAL
WELFARE STANDARDS AND
TRACEABILITY IN ADDITION TO THE
ALREADY STRINGENT REGULATIONS
THAT ARE IN EFFECT AT THE STATE
LEVEL. FOR MARK IS ABOUT AUDITS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIRD PARTY INDEPENDENT ANIMAL
WELFARE AUDITS AT THE FARM LEVEL
IN THE US CANADA AND EUROPE.
THESE AUDITS ARE NEW AND ARE
BEING DONE TO ENSURE FARMS ARE
FOLLOWING ALL FOR FARMING
STANDARDS IN ADDITION TO THE
ALREADY STRINGENT RIGHT
REGULATIONS AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THE AUDITS WILL WEED OUT ANYONE
NOT ADHERING TO THE STANDARDS
FOR MARK IS ABOUT ADDITIONAL
RANDOM AUDITS OF THE DRESSING
AND DIE IN LEVEL TO ENSURE A
CHEMICAL COMPLIANCE.
AND FINALLY FOR MARK IS ABOUT
TRACEABILITY A BRAND NEW
BLOCKCHAIN CLOUD BASED SYSTEM
THAT WILL TRACE ALL PELTS FROM
THE FARM LEVEL THROUGH TO THE
MANUFACTURING STAGE.
ALL THIS WILL MEAN
ACCOUNTABILITY THIRD PARTY
CERTIFICATION AND ULTIMATELY
CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM.
SHOULD CALIFORNIA ADOPT THIS NEW
SYSTEM AT THE FOREFRONT OF
CERTIFICATION FOR FOR AND FORCE
OTHERS AROUND THE WORLD TO
FOLLOW CALIFORNIA'S LEAD. FOR
MARK WILL ALSO SERVE TO EDUCATE
THE CONSUMER AND OTHERS ABOUT
FOR FARMING FAX FAX LIKE FOR FOR
ME CREATES A LOT MORE PRODUCTS
THAN JUST.
FOR PRODUCTS LIKE MINK OIL WHICH
IS USED AS A LEATHER CONDITIONER.
THE MEAT IS USED AS A PREFERRED
LOWER IN THE CRAB FISHING
INDUSTRY.
AND THE MEAT SOMETIMES IS
RENDERED DOWN AND USED AS A BIO
FUEL AND FINALLY IT IS USED IN
THE PET FOOD INDUSTRY.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU AND
CREATE A CONVERSATION ON FOR
MARK.
AS THE BETTER ALTERNATIVE TO AN
OUTRIGHT BRAND BAND THANK YOU
THANK YOU I'M GONNA SEE IF FOR
OTHERS WHO WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
STATE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MATT GRAY ON BEHALF
OF TAXPAYERS FOR IMPROVING
PUBLIC SAFETY WHILE WELL
INTENDED THE INEVITABLE RESULT
OF AB.
FORTY FOUR IS THE RELIANCE UPON
AND WHAT A LOT OF ADVOCATES CALL
FOR SYNTHETIC MATERIALS WHICH A
PETROLEUM BASED.
WALL STREET JOURNAL TWO DAYS AGO
CAME OUT WITH AN ARTICLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE MICROFIBER
IS IN OUR QUARTIC SYSTEMS AND
POISONING OUR FISH CAUSING LIVER
FAILURE.
PREMATURE DEATH AND ENDING UP IN
OUR FOODS THAT WE EAT AND FOUND
IN OUR TISSUE AND FAECAL MATTER.
SO IT'S ENDING UP IN A SHRIMP
IT'S ENDING UP IN PLANKTON
SENDING UP ALL OVER THE PLACE.
PLANKTON PROVIDES HALF OF OUR
WORLD'S OXYGEN SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MICHAEL LELAND FOR COMMISSION
USA WE OPPOSE.
SEVERAL FONG I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION ALSO KNOWN
AS BIZ FAD WHERE AN ALLIANCE OF
A HUNDRED EIGHTY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS THAT REPRESENT
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS.
WITH THREE AND A HALF MILLION
EMPLOYEES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WE BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT OF
MISREPRESENTATION AROUND THE FOR
INDUSTRY AND WE ARE OPPOSED AB
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN THAT WE ARE TO
HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES.
GLORIA MISTREATMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS BILL I THINK
WE ALL -- OR
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR EVERYONE
SUPPORT THE I SUPPORT THE GOAL
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SEEK GIVEN
A NUMBER OF CARVE OUTS IF YOU
WILL ABOUT USE OF THE WHOLE
ANIMAL THERE.
ARE FARMS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT DO REYES RABBIT MEAT THAT
DO USE THE PULSE AND SO I'D LIKE
TO ASK YOU TO INCORPORATE
AMENDMENTS THAT ALLOW FOR THAT
USE I THINK CARVE OUTS DON'T
ALLOW FOR THAT.
BUT THEY ALLOW FOR THE USE OF
THE ENTIRE ANIMAL FOR OTHER
PURPOSES CAN YOU DO THAT.
I'M YEAH WOULD YOU HAVE BROUGHT
THIS UP AS A CONCERN AND MISTER
SALAS IT ALSO BROUGHT UP GOATS
AND WHICH IN HIS COMMUNITY.
I'M ARE EATEN AND YOU KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO USE THOSE
BELTS AND OUR INTENTION IS NOT.
TO HAVE ANYBODY THROW AWAY OF
HEALTH AFTER ANIMALS BEATEN SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON AN
AMENDMENT --
TO SEE IF WE CAN BRING.
BRING THEM INTO COMPLIANCE IN A
WAY WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE AGAIN --
THE ANIMALS THAT WE ARE
TARGETING ARE ONES THAT ARE
REYES SOLELY FOR THEIR FOR AND
WE DO BELIEVE THAT IF PEOPLE ARE
EATING RABBITS ARE EATING GOATS
ARE EATING POWER SHEEP THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE THAT AND
JUST.
TO RESPOND TO ONE THING THAT WAS
SAID WAS ABOUT POLLUTION THERE
ARE PLENTY OF ALTERNATIVES UNDER
OUR BILL SHEEP AND COW --
A CODE -- SO
IF YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
SYNTHETICS YOU DON'T HAVE TO USE
THEM YOU CAN STILL HAVE A NICE
WARM COAT I THINK --
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK THE MISTREATMENT OF FOR
THIS LEGISLATION JUST WANTED --
TO BOOKLET BE CLEAR AT ALL WITH
A MINUTE NUMBER --
TWO SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE
STAFF DID YOU ACCEPT.
THAT AMENDMENT WE ACCEPTED IT
AND YES WE ACCEPT IT THANK YOU
AND THAT'S THE THAT'S THE ONE
PERTAINING TO NATIVE AMERICANS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M I WANT
TO THANK YOU OF MISTREATMENT FOR
OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION I
THINK THE CHAIRMAN AND HIS STAFF.
OF FOR THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS
PROVIDED I RECOGNIZE THIS ISSUE
CAN.
IN GENDER OUGHT OF EMOTION --
BUT I FOR ME THIS IS SIMPLY A
QUESTION OF DOING RIGHT OR WRONG --
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES --
THAT WORK A DIMENSION OF
OPPORTUNITY OF REGIME --
TO WORK WITH THIS IS NOT WHAT
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO DO WE WANT
TO TRULY LEAD --
AND BY LEADING THAT IS BY
BANNING THIS BUT THE HUMANE --
AND NOT AND NOT WITH A TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY SOCIETY --
SO I PLEDGE YOU IN YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND I'M HAPPY
TO SECOND THE MOTION
[inaudible]
TO BIGELOW [inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN I
APPRECIATE YOUR GOAL HERE TO TRY
TO BE HUMANE AND ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE RAISED HERE --
THERE ARE SOME ALTERNATIVES AND
SOME INDUSTRY STANDARDS THAT ARE.
CHANGING AND I THINK WE HEARD
THEM.
ARE YOU GONNA BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH SOME OF THOSE --
IDEAS THAT HAVE BEEN PROPOSED
HERE LISTEN TO ON AND AND SEE
HOW THEY CAN BE INCORPORATED.
THAT WOULD BE MY FIRST QUESTION
TO YOU.
I DON'T COMPOUND QUESTION HERE
ALL I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I
THINK THAT THAT'S AN ADMIRABLE
CERTAINLY BUT THERE ARE
THOUSANDS IN PROBABLY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF FOR OPERATIONS
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO SOAR
FAT SOURCE ANY PRODUCT.
AND TO SAY THAT IF WE SET THE
STANDARD THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
EVERY SINGLE FOR THAT SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE HUMANELY
SOURCED --
YOU COULD NEVER SAY THAT WITH
THE AMOUNT OF GARMENTS THAT COME
INTO THE STATE SO THERE BE
REALLY NO WAY FOR RETAILERS TO
KNOW IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
SOURCES IT IS WE'VE HEARD
REPORTS OF RETAILERS --
A YOU KNOW OFTEN OF REACH EVEN
MAJOR REACH IN THE MORE OTHER
PRODUCTS SO THIS THE REALLY THE
IF YOU CARE ABOUT THE COMPASSION
YOU JUST HAVE TO SAY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW THIS
PRODUCT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
AROUND THE WORLD THERE ARE SO
MANY IN HUMANE PRACTICES AND YOU
REALLY SOME OF THE ONES THAT
WERE CITED HERE.
ARE PROBABLY SOME OF THE BEST
DOCTORS BUT YOU KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF COUNTRIES WHERE THERE'S
NO STANDARDS AT ALL FOR HOW
ANIMALS ARE RAISED AND
SLAUGHTERED IN A LOT OF THOSE
END UP IN THE CALIFORNIA MARKET.
SO THAT WOULD BE MY RESPONSE TO
THAT SO GIVEN THAT SAID THAT
OPENS THE DOOR SINCE WE CAN'T
REGULATE THE WORLD WE CAN'T
REGULATE OUTSIDE OUR OWN
BOUNDARIES.
BUT WE CAN REGULATE WITH DAN SO
LOOKING AT THE LOGIC THAT MAYBE
IF WE CAN WORK WITHIN OUR OWN
STATE BOUNDARIES WHERE WE CAN --
HANDLE THOSE TYPE OF REGULATIONS
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE SOLD HERE ARE HUMANELY
TREATED WITH THOSE TYPE OF
REGULATIONS SO THAT WE DO HAVE A
QUALITY ASSURANCE PROGRAM.
WHEN WE DO HAVE A PRODUCT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA?
SO MAYBE YOU CAN WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THAT DEALING WITH THAT
SECOND QUESTION.
GOING TO MR LEVIN'S POINT.
HI GOING BACK TO THE FOUR H. AND
FFA DAYS --
THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS OUT
HERE IN THE WORLD THAT HAVE
RABBIT FORM SIR PEOPLE HAVE TO
GO FARMS BOTH.
LARGE CODES AT ME CODES.
AND FOR THE FOR AN AS AS WELL AS
THE PICNIC TYPE CODES.
YOU'RE NOT WITH THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FOR ALL OF THEM ARE
EDIBLE PRODUCTS THAT ARE BEING
CONSUMED.
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO TAKE A MINUTE AND TRY
TO ADJUST FOR THAT.
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LICENSES CELLS TAGS FOR DEER AND
BEAR IN CERTAIN --
ANIMALS EVEN WHILE TAKES.
WELL IT'S BEEN MY PASSION OF AN
ISSUE --
THOUGH THAT THOSE ANIMALS.
WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO USE THOSE
HEIGHTS.
AS PART OF THE TAKES A DOES YOUR
BILL.
OR WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED
WILLING TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
CLARIFY.
AND ANIMALS THAT ARE TAKEN UNDER
THE STATE LICENSED --
TAG PER TAKE UNIT YEAH THAT'S
THE FIRST AMENDMENT THAT THE
COMMITTEE GAVE US SO SO THAT
THAT IS INCLUDED MAKE IT I
MISSED THAT SPECIFIC TYPE
LANGUAGE.
DEALING WITH LICENSE TIME TO
THAT WAS THE FIRST AMENDMENT
FROM THE COMMITTEE OKAY WELL AS
LONG AS YOU HAVE A A HUNTING
LICENCES LONG AS IT WAS TAKEN
WITH OKAY WHICH IS A REAL
CALIFORNIA HUNTING LICENCES
THINK THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION
ON WHETHER THAT.
YEAH THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE
LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW BUT THAT WAS
CERTAINLY THE INTENT OF THE
AMENDMENT AND IT'S OUR INTENT AS
WELL OKAY SO.
THAT IS THE AUTHOR'S INTENT AS
STATED YES MY INTENT IS THAT IF
YOU TAKE THE ANIMAL WITH A VALID
HUNTING LICENSE OR IF IT'S AN
ANIMAL THAT IS BEING.
YOU KNOW TAKEN FOR FOR ME WITH
IN CALIFORNIA --
THE AND WE HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSION WE ACTUALLY DIDN'T
THINK ABOUT GROWTH SO I WAS GLAD
THAT IT WAS BROUGHT UP BY MR
SALAS AND WE DID HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT RABBIT IN.
WITH THE REASON THAT THE THAT WE
DIDN'T ALLOW ALL RABBIT IS
BECAUSE THERE IS RABBIT THAT IS
REYES JUST FOR FOR AND YOU KNOW
IN A LOT OF PLACES BUT FOR THE
ANIMALS THAT ARE RAISED.
FOR ME I DO BELIEVE THAT THEY
SHOULD USE THOSE PELTS I MEAN
ALL THE FLOAT PHILOSOPHICALLY I
BELIEVE IN USE ALL THAT AND SO
WILL WORK ON LANGUAGE.
TO YOU KNOW TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
LONG AS WE REALLY KNOW THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE REYES FOR
YOU KNOW THAT'S MY INTENT TO
FIND THE LANGUAGE TO DO THAT BUT
GO WE CAN YOU KNOW I I WE HAVE
TALKED I JUST SPOKE TO THE MAIN
DECIDED IN.
OF A PROBLEM WITH IT BUT NOW I
WANT TO I THINK IT SHOULD BE
FINE. FOR ONCE FOR ONCE ONCE
WORLD SO YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
THERE THERE'S THE SHEEP WITH YES
WILL AND THEN THERE'S THE THE
FOR TYPE YES YES THAT'S ALREADY
IN THE BILL SHEARLING IS
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT AS BEING
ACCEPTABLE.
AND CAL FOR AN AND CAL SKIN WITH
FOR WE NEED TO MAKE IT MORE
CLEAR WE CAN WORK OUT AND WE
WILL DO THAT THAT TO I THANK YOU
THINK YOU'RE ON AFTER THE
CLARIFICATION RIGHT WE HAVE A
QUESTION FOR MISTER KALRA.
FAULTLESS DOLLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SUMMER FRIEDMAN --
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
AND YOU KNOW I THINK --
WERE HAVING SOME OF AN EVOLUTION
OF CONSCIOUSNESS --
OF HOW OUR ACTIONS.
HAVE IMPACTS OF WEATHER STOCK MY
GLOBAL WARMING WHAT HAVE YOU OR
IN THIS CASE OUR ACTIONS OF
IMPACTS ON WILDLIFE ON ANIMALS
YOUR BILL IS AS WELL AS A MEMBER.
GONZALEZ IS BILL EARLIER ARE
PART OF THAT MOVEMENT --
OF CONSCIOUSNESS THAT THAT WE'RE
REALIZING THAT.
WE HAVE CHOICES AND OUR CHOICES
HAVE AN IMPACT.
AND YOU KNOW BUT THERE'S
PROHIBITS FASHION VERSES FOR OR
FIRST PERSONAL PREFERENCE VERSUS
THE PAIN CAUSED BY THE CHOICES.
THAT PEOPLE MAKE BUT I THINK THE
THE STATE DOES HAVE A ROLE --
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS NECESSARY. FOR
US.
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT OURSELVES
OUR FAMILIES --
AND IF IT'S JUST A KIND OF AND I
I LIKE THAT THERE'S A HASHTAG
THAT WAS ALREADY MADE.
MAKE COMPASSION THE FASHION
SOMEONE SAID SOME OF THE VERY
THAT I'VE ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED.
BUT REALLY JUST FASHION I THINK
YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN THE FASHION
TRENDS MOVING IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION.
AND I THINK THAT THE THE THE
TIMING IS GREAT FOR CALIFORNIA
TAKE THE LEAD ON THIS AND I
THINK IT WILL HELP TO LEAD THE
REST OF THE NATION AND I
CERTAINLY APPLAUD THE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW AGAIN THIS IS
JUST ONE STATE.
OF UPPERS SOLD AROUND THE WORLD
IF THE INDUSTRY IS GOING TO DO
THINGS -- TO
IMPROVE THEIR PRACTICES THAT'S
THAT'S TO BE APPLAUDED AND WE
GOT THEM.
IN OF OTHER CERTAINLY DISCOURAGE
THAT BUT I THINK.
THIS IS AN ISSUE WHERE IT'S IT'S
PRETTY BLACK AND WHITE AS TO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO AND I THINK
THIS IS A TIME FOR US. TO MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR.
THAT FOR IS NOT NECESSARY AND
THAT WE DON'T NEED TO HARM
ANIMALS IN ORDER TO EITHER.
CLOSE OURSELVES INTO AUTO.
STYLER CELLS AND I I THINK THAT
THIS IS A GREAT STEP TODAY --
BUT AND I REALLY WANT TO PUSH IT
THE CHAIR AND THIS PARTICULAR
BILL AS WELL AS THE SUMMIT IS
ALSO IS A BILL I THINK OUTLINING.
WHERE WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND AND
WHERE WE NEED TO TO GO IN THE
FUTURE SO AGAIN THANK YOU A
SIMILAR FRIEDMAN THANK YOU?
THANK YOU. FOR SHEET YOU --
HAVE THE DIALOGUE ABOUT THE
RABBITS AND THE GO HIDES I
WANTED --
PERSONAL I THINK THAT --
YOU KNOW TECHNOLOGIES OBVIOUSLY
CHANGED I DON'T HAVE ANY FOR
THAT I'M AWARE OF ANYWHERE IN MY
HOUSE I USED.
THE GREAT THINGS A CAPELLAS
MAKES TO KEEP THE RAIN OFF I
MEAN CONFORMANCE SO.
ONCE YOU'RE THAT WITH YOU ALSO
HAVE A QUESTION THOUGH I DID
LOOK AT YOUR MEMBERS I WAS --
THAT DOES AMENDMENTS AND I THE
ONE MINUTE DEFERRED NATIVE
AMERICANS I HAVE --
NATIVE AMERICANS ALL OVER MY
DISTRICT THAT AREN'T RECOGNIZED
EITHER FEDERALLY OR BY
CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW YOUR YOUR
AMENDMENT DID STATE THAT IT WAS
BY TRIBES THAT WERE RECOGNIZED.
AND SO THERE ARE NOT A NATIVE
AMERICANS RECOGNIZE BUT THEY ARE
NATIVE AMERICANS WHO STILL
PRACTICE --
THEIR TRADITIONS --
WITH -- SO I
WAS WONDERING IF THERE I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW EVEN I WAS THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE DRESS THAT EVEN
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT RECOGNIZE
BUT THEY ARE NATIVE AMERICANS SO
I JUST WANT TO BRING THAT TO
YOUR ATTENTION.
SOMETHING I KNOW I'M GONNA HEAR
FROM FROM THE NATIVE AMERICAN
POP POPULATION IN MY DISTRICT
AND THERE ARE MANY THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF AN ACTUALLY THAT
AREN'T RECOGNIZED BY CALIFORNIA
OR A FEDERALLY --
I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT AND WE DO ALSO HAVE A
RELIGIOUS YOU KNOW NEVER
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION SO WE CAN WE
CAN CERTAINLY WORK WITH YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WILL WILL
ENGAGE IN THAT DISCUSSION AS
WELL WHICH WAS OF IMPORTANT.
PIECE TO THE AMENDMENT FOR US AS
WELL.
OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
LISTEN ON UP MEISTER.
YES SIR I HAVE BEEN BOUNCE
AROUND TO SEVERAL COMMITTEES
THIS MORNING --
MAY WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT
COMMITTEE SCHEDULING --
BUT YOU KNOW.
AND WE KIND OF GOT IN THIS IN
THEAND IN THE PREVIOUS BILL --
LOOK I JUST THINK THE BETTER WAY
TO DEAL WITH THIS IN A DEMOCRACY
AND IN A FREE MARKET ECONOMY IS
THAT CONSUMERS YOU KNOW CAN
DEMAND THAT PRACTICES CHANGE BY
THE BY THE WAY THEY ACT.
AND BY THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY
DECIDE TO PURCHASE OR NOT
PURCHASE.
AND IN THIS FEAR THAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING YOU KNOW AS AS A
MEMBER KALRA POINTED OUT.
WHICH AGAIN BRINGS YOU BACK TO
WHAT'S THE POINT OF THIS BILL.
I DON'T THINK IT'S REALLY OUR
ROLE TO DECIDE WHO NEEDS FOR AND
WHO DOESN'T.
AND TO MAKE THOSE KIND OF
JUDGMENTS.
JUST BECAUSE YOU PERHAPS THINK
THAT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A MORAL
OBJECTION TO IT.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY IN SOCIETY SHOULD.
OR THAT WE SHOULD USE THE POWER
OF GOVERNMENT TO ENFORCE THAT
IMPOSE THAT ON EVERYBODY ELSE --
CAN ACT.
IN A DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY WITH
THEIR FEET AND WITH THEIR
PURCHASES.
AND SO I MEAN I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE HERE
IS AND THE ARGUMENT THAT WE JUST
WELL WE DON'T REALLY NEED FOR
ANYMORE OR ON THE SHOULDN'T YOU
KNOW YOU SHOULDN'T DO THIS AND
THAT IN THIS CONTEXT CAN EASILY
BE APPLIED.
TO IT VERY EASILY THE SAME EXACT
LINE OF ARGUMENT BEEF A LINE TO
SAY HEY WE SHOULDN'T.
RAISE CATTLE. FOR FOOD.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT WE SHOULDN'T.
YOU KNOW I MEAN EVERY EVERY YEAR
I BUY A HARVESTER RICE CROP.
I KILL A PLANT IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THAT RICE THAT FEEDS
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
IF WE'RE GONNA ARGUE THAT HEY
YOU SHOULDN'T KILL LIVING THING.
YOUR PLANTS ARE ARE ALSO LIVING
NEAR DISS.
SO I MEAN.
THE WHOLE CAN GO TO A CRAZY
CONCLUSION.
ESSENTIALLY AND SO YOU KNOW IF
IT'S NOT OKAY IN THIS CONTEXT
AGAIN LET'S ALLOW THE FREE
MARKET TO DECIDE WHAT PRODUCTS
PEOPLE WANT AND WHAT WHAT
MARKETS ARE ACTUALLY
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE.
AND NOT DO SO BY.
OF THE AUDIENCE.
PLEASE [inaudible]
ALLOW THE MY CHAIR TO MAKE HIS
COMMENTS AND YOU'VE ALL HAD YOUR
TIMES BIG ALREADY THEY GIVE.
RIGHT I MEAN IS THIS IS YOU KNOW.
I THINK THIS IS A A LEGITIMATE
PRACTICE I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY MORAL OBJECTION TO THOSE WHO
TRY WHO WHO FOR INSTANCE TRAP --
YOU KNOW THAT IS A FORM OF
HUNTING --
IT IS A FORM THE AREA MAYBE IT'S
NOT.
WHERE YOU COME FROM YOU KNOW AND
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
DO -- BUT IN
MY DISTRICT YEAH PEOPLE DO TRAP
YOU KNOW AND AND YEAH THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE YOU KNOW THE
DESIRE TO HAVE FOR AND THE AND
THE AND THE DESIRE.
TO YOU KNOW ENGAGE IN THAT
COMMERCIAL MARKET.
AYE AYE AND I DON'T SEE THAT YOU
CAN MAKE THAT SAME YOU CAN SAY
THAT THAT IS IMMORAL AND WRONG
AND MUST BE BANNED.
AND YET STILL SAY AND WE ALREADY
DO HAVE.
SOME OF YOUR COLLEAGUES IN
WASHINGTON DC HAVE AN OBJECTION
DECALS AND WANT TO MAKE THAT
PART OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
I'M SORRY.
THAT IS WITH THE DEMOCRATIC FREE
MARKET SOCIETY IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH AN AUTHORITARIAN.
ONE IS CONSISTENT WITH A
SOCIALIST.
ONE BUT IT'S NOT ONE THAT I WANT
TO ADOPT.
YOU KNOW HERE IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND YOU KNOW THOSE WHO.
WHO REALLY HAVE STRONG FEELINGS
ABOUT IT MANY OF THEM IN THIS
ROOM YOU'RE ALREADY ACTING?
IN YOUR IN YOUR OWN DEMOCRATIC
WAY OF DOING THAT WE DON'T NEED
TO USE UTILIZE THE POWER OF
GOVERNMENT.
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR POINT AND YOU
HAVE MADE YOUR POINT.
EN EN OBVIOUSLY INDUSTRIES HAVE
MOVED AWAY FROM THIS PRECISELY
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN ACTING SO
THE SYSTEM WORKS --
AND THIS IS WHY I'M JUST I'M NOT
A FAN OF THESE BLANKET BANS.
ON CERTAIN PRACTICES THAT REALLY
ARE ABOUT YOUR OWN PERSONAL --
ELECTIONS YOU KNOW NOT ABOUT YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW AND IT DOESN'T
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT MAYBE
PEOPLE VIEW THE WORLD LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY.
THEN YOU ND MAYBE PEOPLE ARE
ENGAGED IN DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES
MAYBE THEY GREW UP IN.
AND RECREATION IT DIFFERENTLY
THAN YOU DID YOU KNOW AND SO.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL TO ME IS
FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT AND IT.
AND WE SHOULDN'T GO DOWN THIS
ROAD --
BECAUSE TOMORROW MIGHT BE
SOMETHING ELSE IT THAT YOU
REALLY THIS PART OF YOUR
LIVELIHOOD THIS PART OF YOU KNOW
YOUR CULTURE PART OF YOUR YOU
KNOW -- NOT
BRINGING THAT SOMEONE DECIDES TO
BAN AND YOU MIGHT BE OPPOSED TO
THAT.
BUT IF YOU'RE CONFRONTED WITH
THE SAME.
YOU KNOW WITH THE SAME THING.
AND WE CONTINUE TO MOVE DOWN
THIS ROAD WHO'S GONNA BE THERE
TO SPEAK FOR YOU.
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY THE
CASE SO WE HAVE WITH THAT I
WOULD URGE INTO A NO VOTE ON
THIS BILL.
WE HAVE --
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE ASKED QUESTION
AND WE'LL LET YOU CLOSE
[inaudible]
A DOCTOR.
THANK YOU I HEAR --
YOU ASIDE EIGHT THE OF A STORY
AND OF WHAT THE INTENT IS --
AMONG MANY QUESTIONS --
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK OF BY
BANNING --
THIS OF FOR PRODUCTS FOR SALE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT KIND OF WAY?
ECONOMIC IMPACT THE OUT WILL IT
MAKE COULD NEGATIVELY.
AND WHAT KIND OF A RALLY NEW
IMPACT THE TO THE STATE THE OR
THIS TO BRING ABOUT THE IF YOU
HAVE ANY FEE YES I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR --
SECONDLY IF WE MAKE --
THIS PRODUCTS --
THEN FOR SAY --
IN OUR STATE.
AS YOU HEARD A WHILE AGO THAT
THE WE CANNOT CONTROL THE WORD.
OF THE SELF PRACTICE MAY BE --
CONTINUE IN OR THE STATE SO IN
OTHER COUNTRIES AND IF I DESIRE
WHEN I TRAVEL.
I CAN BUY THEM.
IN A IN A ESOS JUSTO OF CREATING
INCONVENIENCE SO FOR THE ON A
CONSUMERS.
AND THIRD PARTY WE CAN SAY SO IN
TO THE ANY MARS SO.
AS SUCH --
OR LIVES MATTERS SO --
BUT THE SOME ANIMALS.
THAT WE CONSUME US SUCH AS A
LAMB.
WE CAN KILL THEM AND EAT THEM
DOES.
NOT IN IN KHOMEYN BUT THE
SOMEWHAT THE PRODUCTS --
THAT THE WE CAN USE. FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION OF FOR OUR NECESSITY
AS SUCH AS THOSE ARE NOT THE
HUMANE HOW DO YOU REALLY DEFINE.
OF THOSE KIND OF A DEFINITION
SOME ON A DIFFERENT ANIMALS.
THANK YOU I'M.
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST TRIED OUT
QUICKLY ANSWER THE QUESTIONS IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC IMPACT I CAN'T
GIVE YOU ANY EXACT FIGURES BUT
WE THE BILL STILL DOES ALLOW THE
SALE OF SOME OF CERTAIN FOR
PRODUCTS.
CAO SHEEP.
LEATHER SO IF THEY ARE A
BUSINESSES THAT ARE SELLING
THOSE KINDS OF PRODUCTS.
THEY WOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO SELL
A MAIN CORE FOX BUT THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO SELL THOSE OTHER
TYPES OF FURS AS WELL AS
SYNTHETIC FIRST.
SO YOU COULD STILL HAVE A STORE
JUST BE SELLING A DIFFERENT TYPE
REFER -- IN
THEN ABOUT YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
BUYING ELSEWHERE THAT IS TRUE
YOU COULD BUY THE FOR ELSEWHERE.
BUT US IN CALIFORNIA ACTING DOES
SEND A VERY STRONG MARKET SIGNAL
IT WOULD CHANGE OUR PRODUCT
STREAMS FROM MAJOR MANUFACTURERS
AS WE'VE SEEN WITH OUR FUEL
VEHICLE STANDARDS FOR INSTANCE
WHERE THEY DON'T JUST MAKE.
THOSE HIGHER STANDARD VEHICLES
FOR CALIFORNIA THEY MAKE THEM
FOR THE REST OF THE NATION SO WE
EXPECT THAT TO HAVE AN IMPACT
BUT YES YOU COULD CERTAINLY BY
FOR SOME OTHER PLACES.
AS YOU CAN MANY PRODUCTS THAT WE
DON'T ALLOW HERE FULL GRAW AND
YOU KNOW OTHER THINGS --
AND I WOULD JUST ARMED.
SAY TELL MISTER GALLAGHER I DO --
HERE YOUR ARGUMENT AND I
UNDERSTAND IT AND I YOU KNOW AND
I APPRECIATE IT AND I THINK THAT
IT'S THE CORRECT QUESTION TO ASK --
BUT I WILL SAY THAT FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PRODUCT I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE TYPES OF FOR
THAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO IMPACT.
ON OUR HUMANE I DON'T THINK THAT
THEY'RE HUMANELY RAISED I DON'T
THINK THAT YOU CAN TAKE AN
ANIMAL THAT IS NOT A
DOMESTICATED ANIMAL BUT A WILD
ANIMAL LIKE A FOX SOME INK.
AND REASON IN A VERY SMALL CAGE
ANY HUMANE WAY IT'S JUST NOT
POSSIBLE THESE ARE ANIMALS THAT
WANT TO ROMAN BE FREE.
AND WE KNOW FROM NUMEROUS
NUMEROUS EXPOSES HAVE BEEN DONE
ABOUT THE FUR INDUSTRY AROUND
THE WORLD THAT WHILE THERE MIGHT
BE SOME.
SOME YOU KNOW.
A GOOD ACTORS IN THE SPACE THERE
ARE A LOT OF BAD ACTORS IN TERMS
OF HOW THE ANIMALS ARE
SLAUGHTERED AND TRAPPED.
AND SO I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AS A STATE TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PRODUCTS ARE
CAUSING MISERY AROUND THE WORLD.
AND THIS IS A PRODUCT THAT BY
ITS NATURE IS NOT ONLY
UNSUSTAINABLE BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE SOME BY PRODUCTS
THAT ARE USED THESE ANIMALS
WOULD NOT BE RAISED.
THEY DID THESE WOULDN'T EXIST IF
IT WASN'T FOR FOR A THERE AND
IT'S NOT A BY PRODUCT OF SOME
OTHER USE THEIR THERE FOR ONLY
ANIMALS THAT ARE BEING TRAPPED.
AND REYES AND THAT IS IN ITSELF
NOT SUSTAINABLE FOR IS EASILY
REPLACEABLE SO IT'S NOT A GOOD
USE FOR YOUR SUIT GOOD USE OF
RESOURCES --
WHEN THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES LIKE
ANIMALS THAT ARE YOU KNOW WITH
THE THE FOR IS A BY PRODUCT OF
FOOD PRODUCTION SO I THINK IN
ITS VERY NATURE IT'S
UNSUSTAINABLE I BELIEVE IN ITS
VERY NATURE IT'S IN HUMANE?
AND I DO THINK THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
THOSE WHO CAN'T SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES AND LASTLY I'D SAY
BUT FOR DOES NOT IN BODY
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES.
OUR VALUES ARE OF COMPASSION AND
SO I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR
THE STATE TO SAY.
THIS IS A A PRODUCT THAT WE
BELIEVE DOES NOT IT DOES NOT
FULFILL THOSE VALUES IT'S NOT
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE IN OUR STATE --
GIVEN ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT
PROBLEMATIC ELEMENTS AND BY
ACTING WE DO.
SEND A SIGNAL SAY ONE OTHER
THING I REPRESENT HOLLYWOOD I
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT TO DO WERE FOR SOMEONE
I'VE SPOKEN TO THOSE PEOPLE THEY
DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT FOR COMES
FROM THEY DON'T KNOW HOW IT WAS
RAISED I DON'T KNOW WHAT COUNTRY
CAME FROM.
WHEN YOU TELL THEM A LOT OF THEM
ARE KIND OF HORRIFIED SO IT'S
NOT THE CASE THE CONSUMERS ARE
ALWAYS MAKING AN EDUCATED --
DECISION AND I THINK THAT THIS
ALSO SENDS A SIGNAL TO THEM THAT --
THAT MAYBE THERE'S YOU KNOW
RATHER THAN GOING OUT OF STATE
TO BUY FOR TO GO TO A MORE
HUMANE ALTERNATIVE AND WITH THAT
I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THERE
IS A MOTION BY MISTER KALRA
SECOND WAS GLORIA.
LAST FOUR ROCCA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA HI
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CHOI KNOWN CHOI KNOWN
CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALLY.
ELLIE NO FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN MY
CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
CALLER ID LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO SALAS
[inaudible]
WOOD [inaudible]
THE YES [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP THE CALL OPENED FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
SERGEANTS IF YOU'LL LET THE
OTHER MEMBERS KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP IT OPEN FOR FIVE
MINUTES.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
SOMEONE.
I DO WANT.
WE'LL START.
WITH THAT ON TO THE FIRST BILL
WHICH WAS A. B. TWO OH NINE
LIMON [inaudible]
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE OUR MEMBERS WERE
ABSENT.
AB ONE NINE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER I CHIU [inaudible]
CHIU I KALRA [inaudible]
I SALAS [inaudible] NINE TEN
THAT PASSES.
IT WILL GO TO THE NEXT BILL
WHICH IS A. B. TWO SEVEN THREE
GONZALEZ.
AB [inaudible]
TWO SEVEN THREE CHIU.
CHIU I KALRA.
ALRIGHT I SALAS. NINETY THREE
PASSES.
BELIEVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBER CHAD ON AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO THE PROPOSED THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
GALLAGHER --
GALLAGHER AYE AYE CHIU.
CHIU I KALRA.
COLOR II SALAS. THIRTEEN TWO
ZERO EIGHT PASSES.
AND THE THE RULES.
ON THE ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE
RULES GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER NO [inaudible] TWO
CHIU I KALRA. NINE ZERO FOR THE
RULES YEAH WE HAVE ENOUGH
[inaudible] NINE NINETY THREE
SO WE HAVE.
AN ADD ON EVERYTHING ELSE.
OKAY.
WE WILL LEAVE THE CALL OPEN FOR
ANOTHER THREE MINUTES FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THIS IS GOOD
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE CAN OPEN THE CALL.
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO REGISTER
THEIR VOTE SOME.
FROM THE TOP.
AB FORTY FOUR FRIEDMAN.
AB FORTY FOUR SALAS SALAS.
HOUSES.
NINETY FOUR AB TWO OH NINE SALAS.
FROM THE SIDE.
AB TWO SEVEN THREE SALAS
[inaudible] NINETY THREE
CONSENT CALENDAR SALAS.
FROM THE FIVE ON THE ADOPTION OF
COMMITTEE ROLE FOR US.
I THINK YOU WILL LOVE.
ALLOW FOR DOCTOR WOULD TO ADD ON
TO BILLS.
AB AB.
FORTY FOUR I'LL BE FORTY FOUR
WOULD WOULD AYE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD --
AT THIS TIME WE WILL ADJOURN.
OUR WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE HERE